and I won't even get into the Myriad of
reasons but basically there was like a
potential legal precedent that would
have been like would have altered Pepsi
stock price forever if we pissed off
Daniel de Lewis or whatever so it was it
it was a hold
on that's too tantalizing if you can't
get into it just a little bit because
nothing happened yeah nothing happened
so I think there was a case that perhaps
if this went wrong he may be entitled to
a royalty on every Pepsi product sold
forever can see why legal would push
back
[Music]
Chris Welcome to Austin nice to see you
man nice to see you too thanks for
having me absolutely so we are going to
Bob and weave and do some improv jazz in
this conversation we're going to wind
all over the place let's start with a
basic which is how did you land your
first job my first job was at a was at a
very cool very trendy Ad Agency in
Boston called modernista and I convinced
them to let me be an unpaid intern
because they were so small they didn't
they didn't know how to say no to me
coming in an offering to work for free
so I just graduated college and I got
really lucky because there was kind of
no highspeed internet or anything I just
found him in the phone book literally
and I walked around and it was this cool
office and I so I kind of by virtue of
that I found my way there and they let
me be an unpaid intern and and they let
me write you know website copy very web
1.0 copy for General Motors for the for
the Hummer truck when that was brought
back with the H1 and the H2 and I
decided this was my dream maybe you know
write a ton of web copy and and that was
making me really excited maybe do a
print ad you know back when when there
was magazines everywhere maybe a put an
idea on the back cover of a magazine and
that and that would really be massively
fulfilling so as soon as I got that
internship I just I had to figure out
how to get hired but they but they
weren't hiring and it was very at the
time to go from unpaid to paid unpaid to
paid barely paid but at that time and we
could touch on this it was it was much
more competitive to get to get into the
ad Biz because there just weren't as
many creative options for for career
so we had an assignment for the Dallas
Mavericks
2002 NBA program like the the magazine
that that people would buy when they
went to mck games and at the time Mark
cubin was was this very out besides just
being Mr Shark Tank he was this very
outspoken NBA owner he was always
criticizing the league and the officials
and he was always getting fined and it
was that was a big theme so I wrote an
ad and it wasn't a particularly good one
it was okay but I wrote even Mark cubin
has nothing bad to say about it with a
picture of the truck which I thought was
clever I don't know if it's going to
really stand in the test of time but I
knew that getting a billionaire to to
give you the rights to their name was
probably you know some something that
had to be thought through where there's
probably some people that would weigh in
on that and I remember this urban legend
again very like web 1.0 which was that
Mark cubin had an email address that if
you could find it and you emailed him he
like wrote everybody back so I kind of
put together a very short concise email
pleading my case I'm an unpaid intern
this would mean so much if you would if
you would let me put this ad into the
world and I made a little PDF and I
attached it and like you know true to
Magic about an hour later oh wow he just
wrote back and he just said go for it
dasm and so he summoned the genie I he
was you know he was right he was there
for it maybe it was because it was ad
about him yeah maybe there's other
emails he didn't want to write back to
but maybe this maybe this worked for him
and so I remember I I printed out the ad
and then I I printed out the email from
him and I put it underneath and I I
showed my boss Lance and he laughed at
that ad and then said you know the the
requisite like we're never going to be
able to do it but but thanks kid and
then you know he turned the page and
there was the email and I think that you
know more than any creative idea I'd
ever shown him and I was doing my best
to show him everything I think I showed
him that I was going to going to solve
every problem with creativity not just
the the assignment and so we we ran that
you know underwhelming ad but that was
enough for him to give me a job offer
for
$225,000 a year which was you know the
best job offer I ever got so many
followup questions so the the first
is and
you may not recall but do you have any
idea what the subject line was or the
gist of the subject line you know
what I don't remember the subject line
but I'll tell you this I think it was
good and considered because I to this
day I receive a lot of
email that's not from you know people
I'm looking to hear from and I know the
power of a subject line so I think very
hard on these things cuz everything is
the communication oh yeah so for example
when I worked at tbwa shy day I would
sometimes cold email clients we' we'd
have an idea for audible or an idea for
Ikea and I would find the client and I
would reach out and I figured out the
perfect email subject which was hi from
Apple's Ad Agency because tbwa is
Apple's Ad Agency and my response rate
on that yeah was killer so I've
definitely learned that that you know
your your first impression is kind of
your only impression so maybe I appealed
to his his kindness maybe it was
desperate unpaid intern I don't know I
don't know what but it maybe you
appealed to his level of get done
he he appreciated the the hoah and I
hope so it would seem to be the case if
he gave you permission so if I ever see
him I'll say a very big thank you he may
end up hearing through the podcast so
coming back to the phone book becoming
an unpaid intern yeah why did you choose
to focus because phone book has a lot of
entries that's right there a lot of
different types of businesses yeah why
did you choose to pursue this particular
company or at least sector everything's
luck you know you can you can be
prepared for it you can have some gifts
but you're an idiot if you don't think
that like that chance and fate and and
all those things because there were a
number of ad agencies in Boston and I
was sure I wanted to to be an
advertising creative person but again
you googling wasn't a thing to do like
the computer with the internet was at
the library you know and I think I I
think it was like
yellowpages.com and I think modernista
was the name of the agency so that's
like kind in the middle that's not like
the first one I think I tried Arnold
advertising in Boston and they they
didn't want to meet with me I think I I
think I just worked my way down and I
think they were it was just the right
place right time where they were like
yeah we'll take Free Labor so it was
just it was really I didn't you couldn't
look up what the client lists were did
you have a pitch or was it I will do
anything if you let me in the door or
was it more specific it was I will do
anything because I had nothing to offer
and I think later I would get my second
job and I would go to someone and now
I'm a copywriter and I would say I will
write on your accounts in my spare time
if you want I would you know you got to
offer whatever you have but but I
started out with nothing to offer so I I
think I knew I was free labor and I said
I would get coffee and and I did and I
got a lot of
coffee we may come back to that there's
a lot of power in being willing to do
the Small Things mhm because a lot of
folks feel like they're too good for it
or too qualified but we may come back to
that I want to ask you for the program
and maybe you already said this I missed
it coming up with the even Mark Cuban
has nothing bad to say about this
particular car did they give that to you
as an assignment or is that something
you just did of your own valtion I think
I graduated from from website copy to
the smallest of of creative tasks and so
I think there was like you know you know
you could write the the welcome signs
for the GM convention and try to make
that clever and you could write so
there's all kinds of like little things
that weren't like the big brand stuff
and they weren't the big TV spot or
anything and that's kind of where all
the focus was and you kind of had to
work your way up to those things you
said that you have to consider luck I'm
paraphrasing here which is of course
true there's certain things you can do
to increase your surface area for luck
to stick to them borrowing that concept
from somebody else I don't know the
attribution and you didn't get a yes
from the first few spots or the first
few companies you contacted did modern
need to end up being a particularly good
fit or
particularly
influential in a way you could not have
predicted so interestingly when I kind
of found you know my own quote unquote
voice it wasn't really modernista was
one of these ad agencies that was very
stylish very European everything was
very cool and and they would they would
put out work that was very Avant guard I
think I later became a little bit more
mass a little bit more comedic in in the
work that kind of came out of me but
what I got at modernista is the owner
was a guy named Lance Jensen and he for
any AD nerds you know exactly who who
that person is because he had written
one of the the best advertising lines of
all time which is on the road of life
there are passengers and there are
drivers drivers wanted for VW MH and so
he had created that campaign while
working in Boston at an agency called
Arnold and he' done you know all these
famous ads I don't know if you remember
there's an ad I don't know what the name
was but it's that da da da song and a
couple guys just killing time driving
around in their in their VW Golf and I
think they pick up a chair and they
drive around a little further they
realize the chair smells cuz they picked
it up off the street and they let it
back out and they drive around and the
line said you know the the VW Golf
everything you need for your life or
your complete lack thereof or things
like that so there's all these you know
amazing ads and there was years and
years of them and so he had struck out
on his own and opened this Ad Agency
unpronounced to me modernista so when I
walked in they had a crew you know there
maybe 20 25 people there but I didn't
know that I was going to effectively be
interning for you know one of the best
most poetic you know writers in the
industry ever so that was that was dumb
luck but what I got out of that is the
one thing you cannot quite step back and
get from the start is is your taste
level you know at the end of the day
there's it it is a skill it is a muscle
it is an ability But ultimately you're
you're making choices on the ideas
you're coming up with and the ideas
you're approving and putting forward and
that's all on taste M and I I think
there's anyone on the planet that says
they have bad taste everyone thinks they
have good taste sure so I literally
stumbled on the doorstep of of just one
of them one of the most thoughtful
emotional writers ever so I learned my
taste from him and I learned the bar and
the standard and I learned what was
acceptable and making everything feel
brand new and interesting you know he
could write a a line about a car we know
what a car is but he could make a car
sound like this really exciting thing
that you really needed to get one of and
that that's the art of it so I learned
that from him and the best gift you can
ever get is a first boss that that has
great taste or high standards we will
come back to taste yes almost certainly
but I'm going to bookmark that I'll say
a few things and this is context you did
not have before we started recording but
as I began to explore entrepreneurship
MH all of the books almost all of the
books that I first read were on
copywriting MH so CES and all of the
classics I also bought as many books as
I could possibly find and afford on
print advertising because at the time
this is let's call it
2201 print was still a thing yeah and it
is still a thing to a lesser and lesser
level but I was going to be doing a lot
of direct response advertising in
magazines so I had swipe files I had a
three- ring binder where I collected
various advertisements I also bookmarked
a lot of advertisements one of which was
the VW campaign that you just mentioned
yeah and I am endlessly fascinated by
copy because it's
effectively at its best I think sort of
poetic mind control right the idea that
I'm making these sounds that are coming
out of my
face that are instantaneously
registering semi- instantaneously
through your senses into your brain and
then facilitating thought is pretty wild
when you sit down and think about it and
no I'm not on drugs people at the moment
just to be clear I suppose my next
question is actually bridging MH the
bookends of where we started which is
this cold email to Mark cubin and then
an email that you sent to my team and
the reason I think this is perhaps fun
to unpack is that a friend of mine asked
me earlier today she said how many
guests have you booked who have cold
emailed you and I thought and I said I
honestly can't even think of three
yeah but your email worked which one
would hope given your track record right
I was like okay so like this guy knows
how to play the game and he knows how to
get my attention he knows how to get it
surfaced at least to my attention and
now we're sitting here so when you
thought about that email how did you
think about crafting that or any email
like it honest answer yeah I think I
have the muscle memory now so I don't
think I don't think I had to really sit
down I think I made the connection I
thought I really I really want to talk
about this with a broader audience and I
want to get more people thinking about
advertising and I want people to think
about it as a career so I had that
thought and then I found my found my way
to you via our mutual friend Zach
because that's that's part of it but the
muscle memory for me is not only coming
up with ideas the other muscle memory is
actioning and executing them it's one
thing to have all these great thoughts I
know people that are so much smarter and
more interesting than me but it's also
comparing that with this knowing how to
do it m so I hope I had a good subject
line and I hope and I hope I was brief
and didn't oversell because no one likes
that and and I think that's probably
probably what I would have stuck to I
think I was kind of doing what I do M I
have your email in front of me so let me
share my perception of my read of the
ingredients first thing is you get to
the point it's not six paragraphs of
meander in life story you sort of
established that you know the podcast
very quickly within the first two
sentences and you mentioned very quickly
your credibility so 21 years Chasing the
Dream to much success and far more
failure okay well kind of failure right
so you're prompting sort of questions
immediately Sizzle reel of some of my
career highlights short Sizzle reel
which you can accomplish in different
ways by the way it could just be a few
bullets but like credibility up front in
other words and then thanks for
entertaining this like here are some
macro topics we could talk about so like
immediately getting into topics which
prompt questions in my mind including
several that I would want answered not
just for my audience but for myself as
so I would say establishing credibility
yes you have the connection but that
actually is just table sticks right
right and particularly if I'm not
extremely close to the person making the
introduction if it's someone close I
know they're putting their social
capital at risk with me so it gets in
some cases elevated by someone on my
team right but this is It's very rare
that something like this will convert
but I was interested in exploring as you
led to in the second probably second
paragraph of your email not just the
successes but also the failures sure but
first we're going to look at the the
nurturing and development of your
ability to get things done on the
execution side well before that by the
way I think in that email and and maybe
the big thing about it because we also
when we pitch as an agency we show up
with 10 people and a 100 page deck and
our capabilities and the ideas we're
going to bring forward but the thing you
you never can lose sight of is whomever
makes their idea easier to buy will sell
their idea whoever makes their product
easier to buy so I think anytime either
I position the work or our company or
myself I try to I try to give you a
couple reasons for a yes MH rather than
relying on someone else to put together
my Cinderella story for me yeah I mean
you had different headings too you had
macro topics and then later on
techniques truths Etc and these were
very well thought through so in effect
you made it easy to say yes because I
like okay you've done 50% of my research
for me in a sense right which makes the
yes easier that's right there we go and
by the way folks number one this is not
an invitation for thousands of people to
C email because trust me it's not going
to work I'm giving
you the exception to the rule but what I
would say number two is that and then
we're going to go to fatherson trips
that's going to be next step so I'm
going to precede that by preparing this
and maybe you have discussed some of
these bullets before in talks or in
pieces you've written but you've also
the work that you did even if I had not
said yes mhm would be useful in other
places right think about your career
your history the techniques that you've
used is not lost if the first person
says no or the second person or the
third person so I'm just pointing out
that it was well crafted and a good
investment all right fatherson trip to
California I'm going to use that and let
you run with it yes this is something I
it is a formative experience that I that
I only really put together a couple
years ago on Father's Day when I I kind
of felt like I wanted to tell my father
how inspiring he is for me because you
know your dad's your dad your mom's your
mom uh I don't often take a step back
and you know let him know the things he
showed me when I was young how how much
I value them and how much they help
shape me so when I was 10 years old we
took a father-son trip to California and
it was the first the first time I'd ever
been to the West Coast and my father's a
teacher it probably would have been a
family vacation but I think maybe it was
like a you know let's just send the two
of you and on the docket was we going to
go to Universal Studios then we were
going to go to a water park and then we
were going to go to the beach or what
have you and obviously Universal Studios
was the big ticket item because those
were really expensive and that was the
highlight so we go to Universal Studios
and I my mind was blown because I grew
up a little bit of a shy reclusive kids
if I wasn't out playing with the other
kids I was watching TV I was watching
movies so so that world was extra
important to me as a child and I'd never
been anywhere near you know where these
actors were where where these things
happened and so we took the tram tour
and I saw you know the the actual house
from psycho and the real mil Valley Town
Center from Back to the Future which was
my favorite movie ever and and even the
the empty water tank that was you know I
still remember this that it was also
cross purpose as a parking lot but had a
giant painting of a infinite ocean
behind it and that's where they filmed
the water scenes for Jaws and a dozen
other movies and you know all this stuff
so I was I was so excited in many ways
I've been kind of chasing
that rush to production and to sets and
to to where it's happening ever since
but I mean the the guy walking past the
tram with the paint bucket I wanted to
be him because he was doing something so
anyway just it just blew my mind how old
were you at the time it's probably N9 or
10 mhm so it blew my mind so we go to
the hotel and and call my mom and report
on the day and I said look I I know we
can't go back but I would give anything
to go back and and that was that and and
and I appreciated it and then the next
morning my father wakes me up you know
maybe at at like five or six am which is
really early to to a nine-year-old it's
pretty early for PR a lot of people
pretty early for a lot of people and we
get in the rental car and I don't really
know where we're going and we drive 20
30 minutes and we wind up in some kind
of a strip mall and we go into like a
storefront I remember this and there's
like a a row of chairs and like an old
school projector I guess the at the time
it wasn't old school it was just a
projector because it was 1990 like
overhead transparencies or something
like that all that stuff like the sheets
and and it was a 4H hour time share
meeting for for a new development in
Anaheim and they start it was a hard
sell I mean they were coming in they
were talking about these are going to go
fast and people would raise their hand
and get up and get get and buy into it
and then after they left the room they
would like lower the price and I mean it
was really I was worried by I didn't
know what was going on I was worried my
father was going to buy one of these
things and so after this whole four
hours is over we we kind of go to the
front to sign out and you know we were
rewarded with two super crisp day passes
to Universal Studio so my father figured
out that that was was another way to get
access and so we burned rubber got to
the park and we rode the the Backlot
tour like until they literally kicked
kicked us out of Universal Studios and
you know and I think that was what we're
getting at with this story was this this
is my father kind kind of taught me the
the definition of creativity which is
really just looking at any situation and
finding another way because he didn't
overextend himself and buy tickets he
couldn't afford he didn't get mad or
upset that he couldn't get them he
bypassed all of that and he was just
always going to figure out another way
and that's who he is and that's how he
lives his life and my father is is a guy
who kind of has never let his his
situation ever determine where he was
going to go and I it rubbed off on me
and a number of other ways it it kind of
made me a little audacious or precocious
and so I was a very shy kid you know I
was very little and and we moved around
a lot so I was kind of every couple
years I was a new kid why did you move
around a lot my father is a very
ambitious teacher and he became a
Headmaster and became a professor and he
pursued a a doctorate so we kind of you
know would move around every couple
years to to wherever you know fit and I
think I wasn't a great athlete I wasn't
a great student I was I was small so I I
kind of I felt like okay I'm not going
to I'm not going to kill it in seventh
grade so I'm going to buy my time so I
probably spent a lot of time observing
people which helped me as a creative
person but what would happened is I
lived this double life where at school I
was this you know kind of quiet nice
invisible kid and then I would Chase my
passions and take these moonshots in my
personal life so I love the New York
Knicks they were great in the 90s I
don't know if you're an old school Hoops
fan oh I I remember the okay Starks
Mason Oakley Ying that was an incredible
team and I'd never been to a Knicks game
but I loved them and I never missed
watching one so as I watched it I
absorbed everything so when Marv Albert
would reference that the Knicks you know
had a big day of practice at Sunni
purchase before before the game I banked
that and I happen to have a a friend
that I would go see and and I noticed
that the Sunni purchase was on the way
to his house so I convinced him to like
hitchhike there and then we W no
internet we walked around the campus
until we found a giant beige building
with like eight Mercedes in front so
we're like I think this is I think this
is where the Knicks are doesn't look
like student transport doesn't look like
student transport giant Mercedes and we
staked it out and when people started
walking out like trainers they had those
exiton gymnasium doors I grabbed my
friend and we ran for it and we slipped
in and practice was just ending and you
could see kind people were filtering
everywhere and a few Nicks were like
staying maybe to work on some stuff and
I don't know what you know possessed me
but I grabbed a ball and I started
dribbling it and I kind of figured okay
maybe they're going to think I'm like a
trainers kid or something MH and so my
friend who I'm coaxing with me cuz he's
you know my friend Steven did not want
to do this so we start shooting and then
I I swear on my life Tim maybe it wasn't
as like pronounced or as dramatic as
this but in my memory I heard a ball
slap and I turn around and it's Anthony
Mason and John Starks who were the heart
and soul of this Knicks team at Center
Court they go Two on Two And so we
played you know a f minute game the day
before they were playing straight out of
a Disney movie straight out of Disney
movie the day before they were going to
be facing off against Michael Jordan the
Chicago Bulls at Madison Square garden
and so I go to school Monday and I'm
sitting at the lunch table and
everyone's talking about that game and I
can't even tell them because they
wouldn't even believe me that I played
basketball with them the day before but
my parents supported that they thought
it was great I loved I know you've had
Todd McFarlan on before I'm a huge Image
Comics fan I grew up loving him and my
favorite was Rob leld who I don't know
if you know of who had young Bloods but
he actually famously created Deadpool
among you know many great
characters that would come home from
school every day and I found out that
the image office I will remember this
was in Venice California and so I called
411 and I got the number and I came home
from school every single day and I
called the number and a woman would pick
up and say Image Comics and I said hi my
name is Chris I'd like to speak to Rob
lield and she said okay Chris let me
take your number and I'll give him the
message and so I did that and then you
know the phone would ring and it' be my
mom's friend it was never him but I did
it every day because because I just
wanted the off chance maybe that
receptionist was going to be sick one
day maybe she'd have some mercy maybe
he'd pick up the phone himself but I was
I had to talk to him just for the
contact high I just needed that so later
that year we went to the Jacob Javit
Center for like the New York Comic-Con
which was a very big deal in this must
have been like 1990 or 1991 yeah and
instead of just you know going in with
our tickets I had to enhance my surface
area for something magical to happen so
again and my poor friend Steven I don't
talk him that much anymore voice of Reon
who
Shackled Sten God bless you out of
control uh I think we convinced I think
it was my parents this time to to drive
us in early and we with like a few like
maybe 10 or 20 people we went to the
service entrance of the Java Center
where there was some barricades and you
know at this time Comics were big but
the The Limousines were showing up and
these guys were you know getting out
with their teams and so I was here for
it I wanted that chance to see them and
you know lo and behold like the image
crew roll up and at this time they were
really the you know marvel was the old
school and image were these these bad
boys and they all Exodus and it was Jim
Lee and it was Todd McFarland it was Rob
lifeold or whatever so they all walk out
and so I start you know yelling to you
know to get attention just like everyone
else and I swear to God Tim this woman
walks up to me because I'm yelling and
she goes are you Chris and I was like
yes and she was the woman that had
answered the phone there with the
patience of a saint with the patience of
a saint and this is when I said I was
like little she like Lifted Me Over the
barricade and they brought me in and I
got to sit behind the table with those
guys for the whole morning and Stan Lee
came by you know and I got to you know
yes so all that stuff I found out where
the Dave Matthews Band recorded their
albums and I would send a letter and a
self- addressed envelope to make it real
easy for them to say yes and right back
and he became a pen pal for a couple
years but then I would go to school and
I'd have my two big backpack and be a
you know a mediocre student but I kind
of was living this world superhero in
your own way well yeah it just felt like
I was able to create the life of my
dreams even if the day-to-day reality
wasn't didn't totally match it and that
was fine by me so then we Flash Forward
you're getting coffee for people yeah at
modern EA mhm then you catch a break yes
with this amazing email that you get
back from Mark cubin what is the next
sort of Quantum Leap moment which might
have been at the time seemingly small
but some moment some experience some
small or big win where you're like okay
here we go I think I can be really good
at this or something that sort of marked
as a milestone after that does anything
come to mind doesn't need to be
sequentially immediately after that but
something that ended up being an
inflection point whether you recognized
it as such at the time or not I play
golf with my father-in-law I just
learned it so I'm I'm terrible at it I
don't know if you play terribly yeah but
it's fun it's it's a nice place to if
you're on a golf course in the morning
life's not bad mhm I was taught that
when you putt you know if the hole is 20
ft away what you do is you you measure
you know 10 in in front of the ball on
the path to the hole so you don't aim
for the hole you aim for that spot 10 in
in front and I think that advice landed
well with me because I think I was
always I think I kind of had a sense of
my dreams but I was only really looking
at the incremental of okay I made a Mark
Cuban Dallas Mavericks ad now what I
really want is to write something that's
going to be in the back cover of GQ you
know and that was everything so you had
a clear idea though well yeah and it was
incremental I knew that I was not going
to that was the whole do the the Super
Bowl you know my first year I accepted
that but every time it was okay now I'm
regularly writing print ads and and
print headlines okay now like I really
want to do a TV production I really want
to go learn that and do that and that's
bigger and that gave you more weight and
as I did that I slowly aced a body of
work and that's the the beauty of this
industry is you know you can have a a
resume and you can say whatever you want
about yourself but you actually have a
basket of your ideas and you can be
appraised on those so i' built up just
enough to to get a job in San Francisco
at goodby Silverstein which was I think
that was my big break because I was
learning my craft in Boston but I didn't
realized that when I went to to goodby
that was a then and now is still one of
the one of the greatest creative ad
agencies in the world they came up with
got milk for God's sake so you know
doesn't get that much better than that
but when I got there what I realized is
I had I had learned how to write in the
modernista style and that taught me a
great lesson which is that you know it's
not totally about you like as as an
advertising writer you've got to be a
chameleon you've got to understand not
everything can be your voice it has to
be the the correct voice I want to come
back to San Francisco so bookmark for a
second but I made a promise earlier that
I've not forgotten which is coming back
to taste I think this may tie into the
modernista style so could you say a bit
more about what characterized the
modernista style and just a little bit
more about being introduced to Good
Taste because there seems to be this is
an overstatement but a religious divide
among creatives where on one side you
have people who think that taste can be
taught or cultivated and on the other
side it's like that is nature and not
nurture you either have good taste or
you do not
now that might be like two people of
different definitions of God debating
the existence of God which is going to
go nowhere because they're talking about
different things so could you tell us a
little bit more about modern e style
what is that and
then good taste the first thing I'll say
about it too is I don't I don't know the
nature nurture answer but I but I have
personal thoughts but but I think Lance
who's still in my life now by the way he
he was a great first boss but but
someone I you know still talk to
regularly he had a good way of of of
saying it he's very self- effacing like
like many many really talented the most
talented person is usually the person
that's you know least least boastful and
least sure of anything I've definitely
learned that over time and also
radically open-minded versus fixed and
Lance would say that the modernista
style was kind of you put an idea out
there and the vibe of it is like that's
cool you know they really did know how
to do one of the hardest things which is
cool is is or isn't and and it's hard to
convince of cool but there was just a
way of w in there's an ad for the big H2
Hummer truck uh at a 3/4 angle that made
it look like almost like a piece of
jewelry and then the line on it said
perfect for rugby moms but it was it was
smart but it was just kind of badass
kind of kind of sexy kind of those
things and so that was succinct also yes
very very succinct it was very art and
copy it was it was very tight writing
and it was beautiful art Direction and
that was the
Hallmark that was the box there and and
if you came with something that was too
wacky or too too dry or too intellectual
too much like maybe like the economist
or too much like a big broad Super Bowl
ad it it just didn't fit into the kind
of clients that were attracted to
modernista and that modernista serve
service very well so I really learned
how how to find that voice and write in
it and then when I went to goodby I kind
of the four ends of the Box just fell
down and I realized like okay you could
go to Jeff with some something that
makes someone laugh out loud or you
could go to him with something
profound and the the color palette there
because of who Jeff and Rich are and
because of the scale and size of the
agency and the amount of talent that
they' had through the the Halls over the
years the aperture was just wide but at
that point I think some level of taste
some level of maybe standards came of
like it has to feel fresh it has to feel
interesting it has to be succinct like
those those kind of lessons were learned
and then you could apply them to goofy
things and profound things but but I
think it it's like the taste and the
skills kind of were
merged part of the reason I wanted to
have this conversation and we were
talking before we started recording MH
or you asked me rather like what would
you be interested in or what do you
think an audience would be interested in
hearing and we discussed a few past
podcast guests who are very iconic
clastic and have sort of painted a
unique path for themselves with
seemingly very few constraints like Rick
ruin would come to mind one of a kind
and part of my answer was creativity
within constraints because the reality
for most people and the reality for me
more than a lot of people would assume
is that I'm operating with a team or
with contractors or with deadlines I
have constraints
I think a lot of good creativity
flourishes with constraints but when you
have a team when you have a boss when
you have clients you have to navigate a
whole host of different hurdles and
challenges than if you're a solo
operator trying to be a Creator on say
Instagram or Tik Tok yeah which has its
own challenges but they're very
different and I thought that would be
fun to explore so one of my questions as
someone who doesn't know the business at
all really or very very little as you're
building the portfolio mm you could have
a portfolio that doesn't pull its weight
after a few years right there's the
possibility you assemble a portfolio
that doesn't get you to the back cover
of GQ yeah that doesn't get you to Super
Bowl ads how did you think about and I'm
not sure how much agency you have with
this I guess pun intended building a
portfolio that would get you closer to
the hole it's like okay you can measure
20 in out for that putt or whatever it
might be how did you think about
portfolio construction and making
progress towards bigger and more
interesting things I suppose it's what
you're attracted to and what you loveh
and I'm not here to say that all of
advertising when you drive past a
billboard or flick on Instagram or turn
on the TV it it's mostly not good M and
and in fact most of it is is not even
ideas I think oftentimes it's just
information so there's a lot of it and I
I think for whatever reason my interest
in the industry latched on to to
somewhere in the top 20% I don't think I
wanted a job in advertising I think I
wanted to express myself in an
interesting way and I wanted to put
provocative or interesting ideas into
the world so I
think I think I was obsessed with with
the best of the best and so I would in
my early years spend time with award
show annuals and look at what the
industry said were the best and I'd form
my own opinions and I would say okay I
think that's okay but I love that or I
want to you know so I started to shape
where I wanted to go with it and then of
course you figure out okay what are the
places or or who are the people that are
doing that and how the hell do I get
near them and that became and are those
people who are on the creative side are
those clients are those both how much
control do you have over what you do
next right like one thing you said that
surprised me was you came up with an
idea for a client and then sort of
pitched it to a client who is not
already signed with the agency at right
so I was like oh okay that's interesting
so I would assume in a big agency it's
like we have these clients and like
here's your assignment sure so I don't
know how much control you have in sort
of forging your own destiny with new
clients being around new people like
anything I think if you are being
challenged and if you have all the
opportunities Under the Sun on your in
your current roster or whatever your
workload is then you give your all to
that but if you're feeling like maybe
there's a lower ceiling on some of the
things in front of you then naturally I
think you've just got to get proactive
because again at the end of the day when
the clock runs out or when the year is
over whatever you made is what you have
to show for it so if things start to go
south I mean sometimes there'll be maybe
a host of great clients but maybe the
CEO has very questionable taste doesn't
doesn't like ideas that are too big or
bold or creative and you've got to
account for that and you've got to kind
of hedge on that you've got to have a
lot of irons in the fire and when you're
feeling like things are stagnating
you're going south you've got to almost
invent your own opportunities so it's a
mix how did you get your first Super
Bowl ad how did that happen it may be a
nature nurture thing thing as well if
the if the nurturer is my dad who kind
of figured out how to remove obstacles
to where he was going to get a Super
Bowl brief it is and was a very big deal
but I think maybe 10 15 years ago things
were much more hierarchical I think
today it's not
uncommon to give big opportunities to
all levels of of creative people or any
strategists or account people anyone in
the agency but back then it was very
hierarchical and I went and again this
is like the most 1A thing but I went and
I asked for the assignment can you place
Us in time like where are you so this
would be
2005 m in San Francisco at goodby Silver
scen partners and the previous two years
they' done a Super Bowl ad for Emerald
nuts and so I went to the creative
director of it and I said I very much
love this campaign it's one of the
reasons why I was so excited to be here
if you would have me I will it doesn't
even have to be formally assigned I
would just give it anything to work on
it that was it that's a smart way to
word it make it an easy yes if you does
have to be formally assigned I mean that
probably simplifies the political slash
approvals that's right Dynamic and it
gives it gives that creative lead I was
scoped for two teams I just found a I
just found a third writer so I did that
and I was fortunate it was a guy named
Steve Simpson who worked it was him and
Jeff goodby together and and we got the
brief and the brief was win the Super
Bowl ad meter and and that means you
know to win the popularity contest so we
peanuts are parody so just do our peanut
ad and make it amazing and I remember we
were sitting in a conference room on the
sixth floor and everyone kind of
funneled out and I felt like I was so
close to this chance to do a Super Bowl
ad that I just I needed it I had to give
myself the best shot to win
so the strategist was one of the last
people to leave the room and the
strategists are the ones that work with
the client and they align on like what
what needs to be communicated you know
what are the core elements and and what
do we know about our audience and and
that kind of stuff so this is not to
diminish the role but it's kind of like
an account manager like they work with
that specific client yes yes so to
translate their needs and preferences
and so on to the in-house creative
that's right to kind of to kind of
translate the ask from the client into
something that might be inspiring in a
brief would get the creative thinking
and it was a guy named Matt Herman and I
remember I kind of grabbed him and he
was nice guy and I knew him socially and
I just said hey just tell me is there
anything that I could put in this that
would make the client like it even more
MH and he had said well you know we're
having these conversations about maybe
thinking about peanuts as as like a
source of energy not just like a snack
but something that can give you you know
like a like a pickme up and so I took
that and then I ran and I wrote like 20
scripts but every single one of them had
the the peanuts as this source of energy
that gave you something that got you out
of something that Pro protected you from
something but I made them feel like more
of a utility as a result I kind of
gained the system and then all the ads I
wrote were the ones that went forward
because they just they did more and if
table Stakes are table Stakes if you can
in anything in creativity or whatever
your job is if you can figure out one
more thing that what you're being asked
to do could do and you cover everything
and that you're more attractive you're
more appealing always and I want to
highlight also that first you have to
have the chops like you have to have the
ability the skill set to execute but so
much is left on the table by not asking
targeted questions right like you asked
the question which is like the spell yep
that provided you with the information
you needed to use the hook yeah right
that the client would respond to all
right so then then what happens what
does the approval process
or production process in brief look like
all right so you send off these 20 yep
different scripts for like I don't know
how long the spot is 30 seconds 30
seconds so it's you know fits in a page
the average 32nd spot is like three4 of
a page in a script how much does a Super
Bowl ad cost these days just these days
oh boy oh boy I want to say like a 30 is
like six or 7 million six or 7even I
think a I think a 60 is somewhere in
like the 10 to 12 MH at this point I
think Super Bowl was the Super Bowl but
I think it was like a million in 20056
non-trivial though I mean this is a big
bet also reputationally a big deal for
people within the client company all
right yes so 302 spot obviously a huge
investment for the
company if not in capital certainly in
reputation
sure what happens so I wrote a lot of
them
and and we can chat a little bit later
about the the techniques but but I
spilled my brains you know the trick
when you're coming up with creative
ideas I think everyone has slightly
different techniques but I think the one
consistent thing is you have to cajo
yourself to release every possible
thought you can and get it all out of
your head and then when you think you're
empty you have to trick yourself into
coming up with more ideas you've got to
mine yourself you've got to say what is
the ad I think we should make what is
the absolute wrong ad to make what is
the worst ad to make what is the ad my
hero David Fincher would make what is
the ad Peter and Bobby Fairley would
make my friend Jason has one where he
says what would I do if the laws of
gravity and physics were not in place
like you have to with yourself mhm
and it's almost like trying to make
yourself vomit basically I that's
I've never said it that way before but
you got to you got to get it all out and
then essentially you know when you're
when you're a babe when you're young you
bring all that raw material and a
creative director tells you what's good
that's how you learn some taste good
creative director so these three are the
interesting ones as you get better you
start to be able to sift your own
material but you've got to get all the
material out now 20 plus years in I
think I can vomit in my head and extract
the bits but I think that's the the the
journey is get everything inside of you
out and that's and then in the beginning
someone tells you what it is in the
middle you get it out and then you work
through it yourself and then in the end
you can have your private vomits MH but
anyway so I I wrote all kinds of them
and the one that went through I trapped
myself to write it
and a few years ago I was reading
something or I saw an interview the
artist cause K AWS I'm sure you have
seen his stuff he does those big kind of
vinyl like Disney looking characters
with the X's for eyes oh I'd have to
check it out yeah all right got it it's
good it's really good pop art and he
sometimes uses these crazy color
combinations and someone asked him how
he put together such crazy combinations
of colors and what he would say is he
kind of reverse painted himself into a
corner he would start in a corner with a
bunch of colors that didn't make sense
and then he used the rest of the canvas
to make sense of it so he forced himself
to make sense out of what he did here
all the way here and that I learned
later but that was just something I
would do to myself so I started writing
a sentence and I didn't know what the
end of the sentence would be and I would
do that to myself a lot just to force
myself I would start an answer without
knowing what the answer was and then I
would so how would you pick the
beginning I would start with logically
so I thought about the brief I I got to
with my friend Matt was there's an
afternoon energy slump and and peanuts
are a good pickme up so I wrote around 3
p.m. when your blood sugar and energy
are
low and then I sat there and then I
wrote Robert goule appears and messes
with your things and I I didn't have
that idea MH I just started a sentence
and I said finish yeah and
so that was again one of a bunch of
ideas but that was the the idea was
basically to turn Robert gou the now
past but the iconic kuner MH and singer
of The Impossible Dream to turn him into
an afternoon Poltergeist I think I had
also seen that incredible Fat Boy Slim
Spike J video with Chris Walkin you know
I think many of us saw that and went oh
my God I want something like that so I
kind of had the the sentence I wrote and
then I thought let's make this like a
weird kind of dance around an office
where everyone's asleep and Robert goule
is pouring coffee on keyboards and
taping people to chairs and just doing
whatever so anyway so that so it's
written and I think another thing
obviously is I I show my bosses and it's
and it's Steve and it's Jeff goodby and
Jeff goodby is in the advertising world
one of the Mount Rushmore kind of
figures so I also learned that if he's
10 times better than me don't try to
sell him on anything he knows so I you
know so I read it I didn't I didn't
meaning let him judge for himself yeah
okay this one's crazy oh you're going to
love this no I just I just I just said
okay here it is yeah yeah Pro tip don't
ever say that to No it's it's true it's
you're going to love this no don't do
that don't laugh too hard at your own
jokes ah had of time either so they
liked it I don't think they you know I
mean I think they they liked it and
they're like okay that's cool and then
you know what ended up happening again
is you know the craziest ad ideas are
really highly highly rational strategies
brought to life in highly highly
surprising memorable ways because when
we went to the client with it and it was
a guy named Andrew Burke who was the the
CMO of emerald nuts at the time we we
had a few we had a very literal idea we
had an idea about a little Mick from
Rocky kind of coach that was going that
would keep you awake in the afternoon
and tell you to eat PE you know we had
stuff that was a little bit on the
nose but to his credit he didn't see
this weird Poltergeist thing he's like
oh I get it we're going to we're going
to show people that there's actual
danger in being sluggish in the
afternoon and we're going to we're going
to make up what that is and we'll
position ourselves so he immediately saw
pass the the kind of insanity of the
execution to the strategy ultimately
great client does that and great work
does that and I was talking to my
friends Eric and Craig who did the the
Old Spice of the man your man could
smell like and that is also you know a
completely batshit idea but the strategy
was we make body wash for guys but their
lady friends buy it for them and they
said great we're just going to have a
hot guy talk to ladies about it and
again and then they made it entertaining
but it's almost like there's a rationale
behind it yeah and and it's and it's
simple and it's bone simple and then the
creativity and the the surprising con C
you make and the surprising things you
write that's the the magic but but it's
it's always Magic on on top of something
very simple and easy to understand it
has to be so this idea is
sold and I will say to this client's
credit you know it was not over
researched or heavily researched so what
they did is they they put it in to some
quantitative research to show the story
boards we made some storyboards and a
moderator you know shared it with a with
a panel of people and it was not panel
meaning almost like a focus group yeah
yeah yeah like people they like okay
people roughly in the demographic and
read the script it wasn't performed it
was read by a third party and instead of
saying you know the dreaded do you like
it which is how many a great idea gets
unraveled they just said okay so what
what did you
see what did you understand from it what
did it make you understand about peanuts
and you know what do you think of
emerald nuts now was very again it was
asking customers the right questions
yeah I think sometimes when you you you
know the Henry Ford ask people what they
what they want and they'll say a faster
horse I think sometimes when you ask
your audience to tell you what it should
be you get a lot of mirroring but when
you make the conversation about what
what are you getting from it then you
can give them something unexpected and
you can push yourself so we did that
kind of research thank God those are
good questions it makes me think of
something that is maybe only
tangentially related
but something Kevin Kelly who's a friend
of mine who's been on the podcast who's
very in a lot of ways and he has a book
of advice short piy lines that started
as a list of Lessons Learned on his I
believe 68th birthday to give to his
kids and one of them was if people tell
you something is wrong they're almost
always right when they tell you how to
fix it they're almost always wrong yeah
right but people have a gut sense so I
me these questions pair well with that
Insight I think okay so those questions
are asked those question asked and it
passes people say what we wanted them to
say and and of course again maybe the
reason why this one sailed through it I
have many many a horror story was again
because they got a natural energy
message when they had convinced their
board they were just going to entertain
so it was it was already in the bonus
round so it was so it was it was favored
and that gives you you know gives you
that lift so you can move through so
then we we hired a director it was a duo
called the peorian brothers out of
Toronto Canada amazing name Ian and
Michael sounds like an acrobatic Act
froma yeah I know know I know and there
are these two you know former former ad
creatives that became directors and you
know they got into it and we you know
did a call with with Robert and his and
his wife Vera and I thought you know I
was you know we can talk a little bit
about celebrity advertising because this
was my greatest experience because
normally celebrities are very they're
very specific on what they will or won't
do and and there's always some pushes
from their team but Robert just wanted
to know if he could choose his own wardr
and we said actually sounds good so we
filmed it in Toronto over two days and
it was it was very fun again the client
was and this is you know
probably maybe inside baseball in the
industry but I think sometimes clients
become so creative that they that they
mirror the job but sometimes the best
clients are let the creatives be
creative and you're there to say like I
think this is okay I I'm not comfortable
with this here's a note on why making
this change would actually be more I not
less but our client Andrew was just
there to supervise and make sure that we
were getting the right stuff in the can
protecting his investment but giving us
liberal room to play M so it was it was
a magical shoot it was right before
Christmas and then we you hire an editor
separately MH and so there's an editor
named Ian McKenzie who cuts a ton of
Super Bowl ads and and he's very good at
it and early January we go into his his
suite in the flat iron in New York City
and I'm super excited and he plays it
and and I'm super disappointed cuz it's
not didn't live up to all my dreams it I
don't know it feels flat is it even is
it funny you know I see nothing but the
problems with it and what you end up
doing you know with the editors thank I
think back in the day when you had to
cut film with a with a razor blade and
use tape you would debate and edit but
because you're doing things in you know
at the time Final Cut You can try
anything you can you can ready fire am
you can you can make it backwards in
some ways it allows you to explore
anything but maybe in other ways it
takes some of the thinking out of it
which is a which could be a shame but
anyway we go through a couple days where
we try a whole bunch of different things
we try some different music we change
the order of this little afternoon
maraud we experiment and then what I've
learned with the in because I've now you
know been working with him for 15 years
ultimately I we start to feel really
good about it me and the art director I
was working with how much of that was
the product changing versus your
psychology adapting to the fact that
perhaps nothing could live up to the
swirling dream of perfection in your
mind it's the ladder it's the ladder
yeah you're exactly right and what I've
learned with Ian and I just for a Super
Bowl ad we made this year I brought a
young team for the first time to work
with him so i' how fun I'm seeing them
get to do what I did you know 15 years
ago and the advice I gave them is I said
just know whatever Ian shows you first
is going to be closest to where you end
because that's what I know about so we
kind of walked around the Moon with him
and of course it was like maybe some
music tweaks maybe a little bit of
tightening up a few moments here but
ultimately had it but we had to get we
had to get our brains to catch up with
reality yeah and of course you know at
the end of the day when someone has
never seen it they're going to kind of
see the the best version of it but but
you torture it editors are magicians I
mean the good editors in any medium are
so important yet so frequently semi
invisible right it's and I I I think I
am getting this roughly right enough but
I believe if you look at Steven
Spielberg's films and his greatest hits
the greatest constant I believe is his
film editor yet how many people could
name his name I wish I could name his
name I've read the story I've researched
this
guy and he is one of the Masters at work
oh yeah again and again and again more
happens in the edit than people think
you know because it's not it's not
lining it up in order you know it's
speeding up shots it's it's arts and
crafts it's punching in it's you know
the the amount of raw stuff we do in the
Avid where we'll split the screen and
take this take from that and the amount
of experimentation that happens there I
andan that's really you know in many
ways like that's the most important
moment and so we we walked with this
edit and I showed it to to Jeff goodby
and Steve Simpson and they liked it and
it was good and then a very interesting
thing happened I I had it on my I had
the quick time on my computer and I
showed a couple people in the office and
I and I played it why would I say their
name but I played it for a couple people
and they went
huh but this is but this and I and I
distinctly remember this it showed two
or three people and everyone and by the
way like you know I
think some people respond as
professionals they immediately think
what they would have done with the
opportunity maybe or I don't know what
but for some reason and I don't know
why it didn't bother me at all and in
many ways I started getting a little
excited by the fact that people didn't
get it and I've not really unpacked this
I'm talking about this kind of long form
for the first time in a long time but I
kind of felt like there was something
more special happening if it wasn't an
easy get for people M and I started to
think that it might be more
original and I think that was the case
and and I kind of learned a great lesson
there which is once you're you take
feedback and and definitely share your
ideas but once you've kind of locked in
and you're and you're sure you're good
with it you really don't have to look
back you know it didn't rattle me and
I'm glad it didn't and I think to this
day if there's something that I believe
in if I get Luke results it just does
not phase me at all and usually you'll
find your audience people will like it
people respond differently than your
inner circles mhm what happened when the
ad came out it did well okay it did
really well the ad age the next morning
ranked at number one they had an ad
critiquer named Bob Garfield who he was
like the cisal and E he was and PE you
know and I feel like Jeff goodby and him
had went head-to-head a few times and
Jeff wasn't a big fan and but he he
liked it and I think it was you know
kind of early days of YouTube and I
think it was like for a day or two it
was like the number one comedy video on
YouTube or something something crazy
like that so it so it worked and the
sales went up I saw it back then I
remember seeing it it was weird because
it got sent to me yeah and it was on
YouTube I recall this oh nice very very
specifically so I want to unpack a
couple of Concepts slash lessons from a
few different people and I want you to
explain them and then we're going to go
to lying to the CMO of Adidas if that's
the right way to put it that's what we
call Cliffhanger after this commercial
break no commercial break but the first
is from David L bars mhm I'm getting
that right and I'd love for you to share
what advice or lessons you took from him
now one that I have in front of me which
could be a starting point or maybe is
the point make as many decisions as
possible I'm not clear on what this
means but it does peque my curiosity so
who is David mhm and what does this mean
and any other any other Lessons Learned
or principles yeah so David is the
worldwide chairman and chief creative
officer of bbdo and he I worked for him
for eight years and i' I'm kind of not
shy of saying he was the best boss I
ever had and he was the best boss I ever
had because he he was very clear and he
was very consistent and that's what you
need in leadership mhm you could show
him a bunch of work and he would tell
you what he liked and what he chose
right away and that was that and David
wasn't afraid of you know he didn't need
to split hairs he would he would come
give you his response and he knew that
he would make a bigger impact in this
giant Company by going around and saying
I think this is the most right thing the
most creative thing the most interesting
thing and just go and do that and not be
afraid to make decisions create progress
and by the way you know if he picked
something that was wrong well whoopy do
we we'd have to go back and do it again
or maybe we had one that that wasn't as
good as it could have been but he never
inhibited progress he always facilitated
progress by doing that meaning so of
catalyzing some type of Forward Motion
exactly he never would say Let me let me
take this back let me think about it or
let's pull more people into it he would
just give you these gut reads and it
always gave you permission to go forward
and it really taught that someone who's
who's really pushing everyone and
keeping everyone in motion just happens
to always be at the center of so much
and that's why for that eight years I
mean the agency was one of the most
awarded in the world and there was my
little corner of the universe but there
was all these other corners and he just
Amplified himself by empowering his
people and saying a lot of yes sometimes
a no but he was you know he was always
game to move forward were you able to
emulate that at the time in
some small way or is that something that
you were only able to implement later as
you had more and more direct reports I
used it then because well because bbo at
that time was David's place so we David
said to do it David said let's go and we
whether or not I don't think we ever got
to look at an orc chart or reporting
structure I don't think we ever knew
that that carried mustard but a lot of
us loved the decisions he was making and
so enough of us would constantly say
that's what David wants and so whether
or not that was be all endall it became
be all end all and so we were all
emboldened to to make moves but I myself
couldn't there wasn't much I could do in
terms of making your own decisions no no
I was kind of probably working through
my own process but it was invaluable
later because you do see people that in
a high creative role you know you've
you've really got to make things happen
and you will see some people in very
senior roles that really Guild the Lily
and that really obsess over such a great
expression it is and and by the way the
building the lily of of someone who's
looking at a two-minute case study for
an award show and changing the mix on
the music eight times and you're like
listen it doesn't really matter and I
and there's times to craft the hell out
of it but there's also this step back
and I think in our industry and in
creativity fast decisions are are really
stepping back you know as opposed to
getting in the weeds can you say more
about that what I'd like to hear you
Riff on a little bit
is how you think about fast decisions MH
this is a source of constant Fascination
for me it's something I revisit a lot
like to what extent do I prioritize like
speed and just catalyzing things
happening
versus
honing minimizing Stakes I think that's
what it comes down to for a lot of
people it's like what error rate are you
willing to accept right is it
10% and I know it's hard to track these
things but is it like you you're willing
to accept a kind of breakage of making
the wrong call 10% of the time because
the speed net net over time is just a
huge competitive advantage and good for
what you're doing that's a long question
but with a fair amount of leadup how do
you think about that I remember that at
the end of the day it's subjective that
I that there is not it's not mathematics
it's not
mathematical and
so you know I've learned to trust myself
and I've learned that if you AB
something too
long you're lost so I think the more I
get stuck in something the more I
realize I need to make a fast decision
because I don't think Obsession when
you're really deciding go no go good
idea bad idea excited about this not
excited about this I don't think time is
your friend I think time pulls every it
slows everything down it takes the
energy out of it so I think sometimes
you you've just got to let it fly and
then by the way you you can correct and
you can change as you go I mean I've
approved ads that wound up being
completely different ads that were
really proud of so that that's the other
thing is that nothing is totally fixed
and you know it also strikes me that
there are so many things just pulling
from my own experience that get worse
with time and more deliberation like
deals and just deal structures right
negotiating often in my experience it's
like the longer it takes the more that
is a harbinger of pain to come right or
just a bad wasteful outcome that ends up
stalling out right there's so many so
many things like that where it's like
okay if if there isn't some speed to
this likely the outcome is going to be
worse for sure time kills all deals yeah
for sure and it kills momentum it kills
energy and it takes people so if you if
you've got people going if if you need
to take something offline for yourself
just know that their their muscles are
going to cool they're going to take a
break and they're going to you know
restart and and many times you know the
wrong decision can become the right
decision you know if if it's actually an
okay time I'd love to tell you a little
bit about a Mountain Dew Super Bowl ad
we did because it started out as one
thing and it became something totally
different and there's kind of a beauty
in that sometimes the nonlinear way it
really
works so this would be I want to say
it's like
2018 and we are Mountain Dew's agency of
record I'm working at tbw at day at the
time I'm the chief creative officer and
I have these incredible executive
creative directors named Amy and Julia
that run the the Mountain Dew business
so we we got the Super Bowl brief and
the idea we landed was something about
how it was for Mountain Dew zero sugar
and this is like the zero that they got
right like this one tastes so close to
the original that we needed to do
something that was going to cause like a
real reappraisal and so I jotted down
before we started talking I was like
that's right because I couldn't remember
what it was so our original idea was
it's like impossible taste so that was
like the the core thought we were
executing against and Amy and Julia had
this really gutsy idea and the idea and
I'm caving here this idea never happened
was never purchased by PepsiCo so so I'm
get this behind the scenes in our house
at the agency we had the idea that for
this impossible drink we were going to
do the impossible Super Bowl ad and so
what we were going to do is we were
going to announce Mega press release
Billboards front page a variety that
Daniel de Lewis had agreed to star in
Mountain Dew zero sugars Super Bowl ad
and we're going to do it without telling
him and I'm Sonic okay continue yeah and
for sure he would say go away if
acknowledged it and for sure he would
probably cease and desist if not Sue and
our whole idea was going to be we were
going to let this play but we were going
to stay because because this mountain de
zero sugar was so impossibly good you
deserve an impossibly hard to make Super
Bowl ad so we're going to do it and we
were going to even have like a live cam
of a limousine parked in front of his
last known address on the day of the
Super Bowl and we're going to have the
set ready and we were going to basically
film and and live stream like is he
going to come and do it so as I'm
working with Amy and Julia on this this
we're we're loving it we're having fun
and this is when the best ideas are when
you're like we can never do this we're
going to get in big trouble this is so
wrong when when you feel that you got to
stay there you absolutely have that's
where all the interesting stuff happens
so then we started saying okay well what
so what happens when he doesn't show and
so we're talking we're like okay so we
we made this up the whole pre-campaign
all the buzz Daniel de lewi su's
Mountain Dew because he's you know he
doesn't want to be part of this he's not
going to participate but we still had
the this the TV ad so a camera kind of
whines through a set from like in There
Will Be Blood and finds its way into
this chapel and finds the back of this
cloaked character and it's it's Daniel
de Lewis's character turns around MH and
it's will feral in a mustache and a hat
and he does the monologue the beautiful
performance piece of like I take my
straw and I drink your milkshake and he
does and he just goes nuts yelling about
how I I take my straw and I drink your
Mountain Dew zero sugar and I drink it
up and so so then the rug pull becomes
insane so he's not going to do it and
then will frell does an insane Daniel de
Lewis screaming about Mountain Dew zero
sugar so we know it's probably probably
a long shot but we go to Pepsi we go
with a bunch of ideas and we go and the
client was a woman named Nicole and and
there's the CMO Pepsi guy named Greg
Lions who's been there a long time and
he's great he's he knows creative again
when you talk about the kind of clients
you can work with that understand
creative people but also understand
their own business and can can bridge
that that's why Pepsi marketing has
consistently been so strong and so we
show Greg and Greg's like I love it I
love it we there's no way we can do this
and he goes but I but he said but you
know but I will bring it to our legal
because look look I love it I just know
we can't do I love it and sure enough
and I won't even get into the Myriad of
reasons but basically there was like a
potential legal precedent that would
have been like would have altered Pepsi
stock price forever if we pissed off
Daniel de Lewis or whatever so it was it
it was a hold
on that's too tantalizing if you can't
get into it but just a little bit let me
I'll give it look because nothing
happened yeah nothing happened so I
think there was a case that perhaps if
this went wrong he may be entitled to a
royalty on every Pepsi product sold
forever I can see why legal would push
back I'm talking about like a bag of
Fredo LS in Bangkok like is like still
day to gets money would have been the
best thing that ever happened to him but
anyway it's like that guy who had a
phone thrown at him by Russell Crow
that's right man won the lottery
Powerball and if he put that money into
Apple stock now how good is he
doing but anyway got it so legal's like
I I love it we think not so we think not
but this is how it really happens so we
go back to the office and we're there's
new ideas and stuff and we're sitting
the three of Amy and Julia are great
they're working with their teams and
then we would get together for an hour
or two and we're saying you know what
there's just something about that weird
ass scene with like the wrong actor just
screaming about Mountain do that we just
loved we just loved it so then you just
go okay I don't know how you'd ever get
to that without the Daniel de Lewis
thing but let's cut off the Daniel de
Lewis thing and make sense of this and
so then we said okay well what if it's
about Mountain Dew zero sugar is like
almost as good as the original or what
if it's like as good as the original if
not better that's our idea and we put
the wrong person in an iconic scene and
have them go nuts and make it just
because we knew that when we saw the
will Ferell idea we're like I just want
to see that so then we knew okay if you
have something you people want to see
don't leave it so then we said okay
maybe maybe it's Cast Away maybe it's
There Will Be Blood maybe it's the
shining and that's what that's how we
landed The Shining where we
recast with Brian Cranston and Tracy
Ellis Ross remaking The Shining but
again he's just he's ranting and loning
about Mountain de zero sugar and so
that's how we got to that M but we would
never got to that if we didn't just go
on go on a weird journey and stay
creative the whole way I want to come
back to something you said in passing
that I'd love to hear more about and
maybe you have another
example and this ties into Jeff
goodby make sure you always feel like
you're doing something vaguely
naughty right so that feeling of like oh
we're never going to get away with this
or like ah you use slightly different
wording but could could you tie these
things together because that type of
indicator right that I want to
understand what that feeling is and how
you actually use it because for instance
this is not 100% but for me there is a
certain like physiological quickening
that I experience have experienced
before almost all of my best investments
there's like there's an obvious signal
that I've learned to tune into it's not
right 100% of the time but the hit rate
is very high yeah so what is
this well I mean it's you know or how do
you use it any way you want to tackle it
well I mean that by the way the the
thing I love by the way about asking
people advice is they give they give you
advice but but people tell you who they
are when they give you advice too and
that and that's Jeff you know Jeff is a
super smart guy who went to Harvard and
wrote for the the Harvard Lampoon and he
he happened into advertising but he is
just he's just a viby really smart guy
and I think he he kind of behaves like
he wants to around you know and
he's a and he's a serious businessman
and he can talk to the CMO and CEO of
any brand he works with and totally
explain why he's doing what he's doing
but he has this way about him where it's
going to be fun and and some days you go
to work and it's you know your deadlines
are are tough and the client pressure is
tough but he just always behaved like it
was it was fun like he was having fun
whether he was or wasn't and that kind
of vibe is great and that does embolden
you to say okay we should be thinking
about this as as a form of play mhm in
the day-to-day you don't it's about
engineering and it's about we have to
get this just right and we have to hit
this timeline and we have to make
everything neat and tidy but it's really
our responsibility to make it closer to
Art because that's what people respond
to uh people don't respond to tons of
rational drivers people don't respond to
things that have been focused grouped to
death it's our job to sort of find the
line and find like the The Edge and stay
there and that kind of ADD ude gives you
that permission that like if you're
feeling like this could be wrong you're
you're probably on to something and if
it feels dead right you're probably dead
in the water are there indicators for
that right so for instance I'm making
this up but you're going Blue Sky you're
coming up with a lot of bad ideas yeah
getting things out of your head so you
can
hopefully sift mhm you know the sift the
vomit ex sift the vomit exactly it's a
good commercial visual for you somebody
vomiting into their old gold pan over a
river in any case in terms of doing
something wrong or that type of
characteristic that is it's a scent
Trail for something promising right what
are some indicators is it that people
around you are like oh god oh or like
they break out laughing or somebody
above you is like oh I love it but I
don't really want to say I love it I
don't know how to really Express what
I'm what I'm trying to ask but I I think
you get what I'm yeah grasp and there's
different feelings I was a very good kid
but like sometimes when you're
presenting an idea and you think you
might get it through if you feel like
maybe what you think you'd feel like if
you were shoplifting a Snickers bar
that's one tell is when you're like oh
boy if I get out of this meeting so if
you know you're getting away with
something if and if you feel that in
your bones that's something if people
are nervous and they start to scenario
like we all love the idea but a scenario
plan and the other is if you just can't
get it out of your head if you become a
dog with a bone and like us creatives
you know
we are dying to get our best ideas into
the world we become insufferable when
when we attach to one and that actually
is a pretty good segue to the Adidas
story if you want because that that's
one where we we got away with one so we
are going to get to the Adidas I'm going
to put one thing in between which
is and you may have to help me with the
pronunciation here Tor myin yes getting
it yep all right executive at Apple
Apple CMO specifically has said what a
worldclass agency partner does is quote
unquote reduce things yes what does this
mean to you well it's the case for
Creative agencies
because
if if I'm a Soap Company I could
hire us or I could just make our own ads
well I say our soap's the best soap
obviously and we put love into it and
our people you know you you start to
want to say everything and you want to
say your polyana version of it and I and
I think an agency partner thought you
said polyamorous version of it for a
second polyana version of it no comment
on Poore that's a whole other topic we
are in Austin Land of Plenty anyway
continue what an agency does is is the
clients come and say we want to say this
and this and this and we say no no one's
going to Care no one's going to care
that you think your soap makers of the
best soap makers no one's going to care
that you're saying everyone says the
ingredient look we show you everyone
says ingredients what you get from
is your jumble of all the things you
want to do and we strip it down to like
the most compelling core truth about why
your product or service or offering is
compelling so everyone adds and really
what you want from us is to subtract and
come to you with like the one thing and
passionately and say we we know and we
know communication and this is this is
what you have to do to make your point
so it really is the the art of editing
and just down down down down down any
examples that come to mind I mean this
is not exactly a statement but you know
G milk is a pretty good I mean it's an
attention grabbing
distillation for messaging purposes but
do any other examples come to mind of of
reducing yeah anything good I mean
anything good I think a thousand songs
in your pocket a thousand song I mean
talk about a brilliant way to to get at
the benefit nobody gives a how many
megabytes it's not about speed speeds
and feeds it's about it's about show me
what what about this is magical you know
it's about finding the one magical bit I
think I think you can just look at any
great execution or any great ad and say
okay that that was focused that was
reductive so no I don't even I think
it's kind of that's the difference
between the good ones and the bad
inherently present where's where's the
beef we could go on and on yeah drivers
wanted on and
on all right Adidas this is a good
landing spot because it's like the
Mountain Dew one it's a bit of a
tail love Tales here okay good and I'll
say every every bit of it as much to
knock it get in trouble everything ended
well for everybody so start
there so we are giving an Adidas
assignment not the Big Brand Adidas
assignment that's there's Adidas works
with a number of agencies on a number of
projects but we were granted an awesome
opportunity to do something for tennis
for the US Open what Adas calls
heartbeat Sports which is like tennis
fencing
swimming so we had this opportunity and
we thought okay for our mly crew for our
Squad to get to do something for a brand
like Adidas we're going to show up at
our very best so we so we invited the
client and I'll refer to the client as
the client capital T Capital C yes the
client 18 point and a good client and we
we had the client in and we brought our
strategist we brought a strategist from
another region that had worked on Adidas
we brought a creative team you don't
normally when a client is going to tell
you about a project you don't normally
bring the creative team normally you
kind of understand the project and
decide what you want to do with it and
then bring in the creative team but we
did we kind of full court press we went
for the full court press and by the way
the
another lesson certainly in advertising
but anywhere the more ground you can
cover in a room the better because you
you start further ahead than if you
constantly come together and split off
and come together and split off so Our
intention was like let's let's land a
brief together when you say land a brief
you're basically getting the gig yeah
getting the gig and the strategy and
like what we want to do and and what our
objective is the challenge that we're
going to meet with creative ideas so
we're having this day and you know we're
talking a lot about how and this by the
way is kind of I think the statistic is
still valid but like I mean something
like 80% at the time of of young girls
would drop out of sport due to body
confidence issues or you not feeling
like Athletics were for them because
obviously the the kind of media biases
towards male athletes and so a kind of
an initiative not only with Adidas but
also with Nike and all these companies
is about keeping young girls in sport
because it obviously has great you know
benefits not only that they could go on
to be professional athletes but for
confidence and all you all kinds of
teamwork and all the great things that
come with it so our client was was
excited about the idea of like let's do
something about girls and Sport and okay
we're talking and then our client says
you know we have Billy Jean King you
know she's going to work with us and
we're think Billy jeene King is awesome
you know I mean she's a total rule
breaker Trailblazer she play played the
Battle of the Sexes so how exciting we
had the very obvious idea we're like
well okay for the US Open we got to take
her blue suede shoes and we got to bring
them back we got to bring them back and
sell them so obvious dumb done and then
as it turns out it's a little more
complicated than that they've got to
make that in a factory somewhere else in
the world and then ship that volume of
shoes on a on a big slow ship and so
that wasn't going to happen and so one
of the creators we brought into the room
his name is Ricardo Franco he says why
don't we just change people's shoes into
Billy Jean King shoes and it was just
that and we went okay that sounds
interest that sounds like something I
haven't heard before and we did didn't
know what it meant and we said okay so
would we like you know have like felt
applications that we could stick on you
see if you came in you know wearing a
pair of New Balance you could like fix
them and we kept talking what about
spray pain what if we get like shoe
artists there these people like the shoe
surgeon and all these people what if we
got some of those people and so we
started thinking okay maybe this is
possible we should figure this out and
even someone in the room said oh God
imagine if someone comes in like a pair
of Nikes and everyone was you rubbing
their hands together this was great so a
great lesson is when you get where you
want get out of the room you know don't
let the vibe dip and you start thinking
about all the reasons why it might not
work yeah don't oversell it so I've
learned this lesson as as many of us
have and and seen it in practice leaving
the room you know normally we'd say okay
we'll come back in two weeks and let's
put it in a deck and let's draw out the
comp but in this one we just knew that
the more we sat on it time would kill
this deal time would give people time to
think about the pros and cons so our
team was just go do it just go we' got
money Nancy our president in New York
Lov the idea so we said can we just get
like 10 grand to start paying people to
test don't get client money let's just
do it so we started setting this whole
thing up that's an important point right
let's get a little internal money just
to start it s jump the gun yeah let's
make progress because we saw green light
this is not the kind of idea that gets
green light I had a stolen Snickers in
my pocket I wanted out of that store and
so we start r& ding it and we find
someone that you know Blends a cool kind
of pearl blue paint and we make these
stencils and we start doing these tests
and we have so we're spray painting like
Converse and Air Jordans and we're doing
them around the agency they look awesome
I mean anyone who sees them goes holy
what is that I want that I'm so
into that so we get you know maybe about
a week and a half away from the US Open
and this client didn't live in the
states it was a global client and the
phone call comes and I knew the phone
call was coming and we get on the phone
and the client says I just want you to
know though that we can only have people
wearing Adidas shoes that we can spray
any Adidas any Adidas shoe you want but
we can only have people spray Adidas
shoes and so this is a moment where you
know no because then it takes all the
coolness out of the
idea but if I say no now I mean she's
got a week and a half to like lock us
out of everything and this is the client
and they hold the purse strings and they
have the ultimate say they're the brand
so I can't argue it because if I lose
the argument it's
over so I lied and so I said absolutely
and I knew what I was doing and I knew
that I was straddling a third rail where
if you do something like this and it
doesn't work out for you could be very
bad for my Network's relationship with
that giant company to say the least but
there comes a moment where it's not even
is it worth it you say okay I understand
lawyers are there to avert risk but in
my gut I know that when someone at Nike
sees a shoe of theirs defaced to look
like a Billy Jean King shoe I know as a
human being that that brand will not
come after Billy Jean King's Legacy or
empowering young girls in sport I just
knew it now the lawyer would not sign it
but I knew it so that's the moment where
you say it mhm so our team is still
going and our client is not not at the
US Open our client is still in Europe
and so I'm in Beverly Hills at the
Hilton at the Beverly Hilton with my
partner Nancy my president and we are
filming a big campaign for Hilton and
the morning of the first day of the US
Open my phone buzzes and Amy and Julia
are sending me these shots of like we
stack the line with a pair of convers
Allstars and Air Force Ones and saines
and with the first five or the things
and they took pictures of them and they
sent them to ad Ag and to Hype beast and
to sneaker freaker and everywhere that's
the one where I didn't have the Snickers
bar I was like felt like I was going to
vomit but it was so good and I knew it
was so not vomiting ideas this is like
actually actual vomit like bile it was
like a bile one so anyway I go back and
I sit down at set and I show Nancy and
I'm like look at these and she goes oh
that's cool actually she always says the
word babes she talks like a hollyood
prod she goes that's cool babes and I
was like thanks and and then my phone
rings and I see the number and I say I
think I'm about to really get unloaded
on and she goes good luck and I and
that's by the way but that was the she
was in on it you know and I was like
okay okay I got got I got my anchor here
so I walked outside called the number
back and the client said please hold I'm
patching in our Global legal and I was
like here we go this is it and I
got yelled at I got screamed at I got
you were you said that this wasn't going
to happen and this happened and how did
this happen and who would have done this
and this and that and I I said I told
you this wasn't going to happen it
happened so I accept
responsibility I did not volunteer that
I had endorsed it but I accepted the
responsibility and I said I will have
rpr and the toothpaste is out of the
tube once it hits the Internet it's done
yeah so I said I will have our PR reach
out to all the Publications and ask them
to take it down because I I know a thing
or two about journalists and journalists
would say no thanks it happened so I'm
going to cover what I want but I said
we're going to do that and I said I'm
very sorry and and I understand you're
very angry with me
so it happens and then the little hype
Beast Community love it and then you
know and then it all goes away mhm and
there was no problem and people thought
it was really cool and they got some tip
of the spear cred for doing something
really Innovative and all the the
hardcore sneaker nerds loved it and they
started going for thousands of dollars
on eBay and we made a great case study
out of it and that client was included
in juries to evaluate the biggest brand
ideas of of the year for notoriety for
the highly disruptive Billy Jean King
your shoes idea so the lesson there or
not even the lesson but the thing about
it too
is when you're in a position where you
can gatekeep or put yourself out there
it's like driving a car or something
you're going to change lanes in in
between two and you got to say I think I
can do this and sometimes you got to
pump the brakes and then sometimes you
got to gun it but really like it's a Lon
decision but you got to make it and you
got to have confidence that you're going
to thread the needle and that's the
getting away with it so to use the the
racing metaphor I mean very
few race car drivers who
have consistency over long periods of
time M are routinely Reckless right they
do have to make those decisions but
they're not routinely Reckless you don't
strike me as someone who's routinely
Reckless so what I want to ask you about
this particular decision right this
culus in your mind if you did how did
you rehearse the worst case scenarios
you're like okay I'm going to make this
decision but and you gave me a little
bit where you're like I don't think
seems very unlikely that say Nike is
going to come after a campaign that is
trying to Foster like youth women's
participation in sports that's going to
be a bad look yes it's not 100% nope
right but it it would be a bad look
right so how did you think about the
calculus and just like like okay worst
worst case this is what happens but like
I'm not going to get killed here's what
I thought the truth is as you talk
about what it feels like to get away
with it it's like a dog with a bone it
was like I just knew the idea was so
good and I just saw so much upside and
then the only question I asked myself
was could someone be hurt by this so
could you do something that would
marginalize a person or a community and
no it would have been really pissing off
a marketer and that no one ever died
from that so I kind of that was that so
swing big is a prerequisite for home
runs but it doesn't always work out
right Babe Ruth yeah a lot of home runs
a lot of strikeouts right so what would
be a for you your personal Hall of Fame
failure list if you had to pick out one
that was important in some way like
whether it was just like a very strong
lashing that you got that you learned
from or maybe you took something away
from it maybe it set the stage for
something later any failures come to
mind you know obviously way more
failures than successes but I think you
just have to have a short memory so I
don't so I don't think about them very
much actually I was thinking about when
I was coming to talk to you I was like
we probably that will come up and I had
to dig around not because I haven't had
a million of them but because I just I
wash them out quickly don't dwell on
them no no I you learn what you can you
take that nugget but going all the way
back to to that agency in Boston
modernista we had Napster as a client so
brings back the memories yes so any of
your listeners that are too young for
this so probably when Tim and I were in
college maybe you were just like
finishing college and I was just in
college was in college at some point
yeah it was a file sharing app or thing
I don't remember how the hell we got it
I guess it was like a Plugin or I can't
even recall but it was it was the I
would say to my mind at least there may
have been some predecessors or parallel
tools like lime wire but Napster was the
first time that Suddenly at least in the
popular Ze guys so people could get
music for free yes including new music
and we were I think the statute of
limitations is has run out but we were
stealing but what Sean Fanning the
founder said is no no no we're sharing
and that was the big sound bite and we
all remember that it was he said sharing
and that was like it became a bit of a
joke but that it was synonymous with
that so
Napster turns out it maybe wasn't
sharing and it goes away and then I
think someone buys the the naming rights
or something and it relaunches a few
years later so it relaunches in maybe
2002 as a kind of a like a way to ahead
of its time streaming platform where it
was the proposition was 10 bucks a month
and unlimited plays a million songs and
it was it was a streaming database that
you could subscribe to again way ahead
of its time so we had been given the
assignment to work on it at modern East
and of course we were a tiny agency and
it was way too busy so I so I got to
take a take a big swing and the idea we
had that I had come up with as a
21-year-old or 22-year-old was what if
our campaign was instead of buying media
we share media and what if we took a
million dollars and we just put bounties
and had regular people crash live
broadcasts of every sort wearing Napster
shirts and holding
signs so it was called crash.com
and you know the the bosses at modern
easta loved it because they were kind of
cool and subversive we somehow and I
this is you know I'm talking 2002 2003
this would have been pretty ahead of its
time and we built a website with this
cool designer.com we made a bounty list
and it was all the way from $250 for a
local radio show if you said 1.5 million
songs unlimited downloads napster.com
all the way to if you crashed a
presidential address you got a million
dollars and I think we had $25 million
if you said that line during a live
televised Space Walk So and there was
everything in between of like getting a
sign on college game day or doing this
that so so anyway this was kind of crazy
stuff lawyers were okay with it I know I
know I know we just said something about
lawyers but this thing was done we had
insurance we built the site we even did
an inaugural practice Crasher where two
interns from the company crashed a
morning interview in Boston and
interrupted a live interview with a
little known comic named Bill Burr
W so young bill was playing you know
some crappy comedy club and was
promoting it on you know good morning
Boston and we these guys came up with
the big sign and they're like what the
hell's going on they get escorted out
and then Bill bur's like what the hell's
going the Napster sign what do these
guys do it worked like a charm so so
this thing was was going to go and it
was like within a week of going and you
know I'm I'm 22 years old and this thing
would have been something is overshot
the GQ Magazine cover that I dreamed of
or whatever M so anyway so the the
client has to go to the Napster board to
give them a progress update and the
Napster client is under no
responsibility to share like launch
ideas or activations this fell under so
the client goes to the board and says
okay here's our strategy and we're going
to go to market and we have a new
positioning and this that and the other
and then he says o one more thing we're
going to do this next week and he brings
it up and I'm not in the room but this
is the report we got back that he shares
crash.com walks through it and the
chairman of the board just interrupts
him and just I'm going I'm going to
interrupt you before you finish just to
let you know we are not doing that and
that was it this thing could not have
been more firmly dead but that was for
21 I learned that you get what you need
get the hell out of the room which has
served me well served many people well
MH to not get into ly gilding and see
see what happens when everyone starts
thinking about don't linger don't linger
but the other great thing is the best
thing for me because this industry is
full of a lot of heartbreak and
rejection you have a lot a million ideas
to sell one and I think if that had
happened for me I would have a different
kind of I would have been very
successful at 21 or 22 and I liked my
climb I liked working my way up slowly
and learning my craft and not doing
something that might have made me very
sought after and might have gotten me a
a bigger better job faster so it was a
heartache but it kind of put me right on
the path that I needed to have which was
the long path
m
so many wh ifs in life right like what
if it had happened what if someone died
during it I'm glad if we didn't do it
because it could have been bad could
have been messy could have been very
messy what was the just out curiosity if
the lawyers if legal had given the okay
do you know what the substance of the
objection was by the chairman it was so
long ago I don't exactly remember but I
think it was just I think he just did
not want a problem maybe it was because
something bad could happen or maybe
because he was on other boards and he
didn't want to like wreck NBC's you know
I don't know I don't know who knows but
someone had to kill that thing it was
too it was too scary yeah that was out
there uh question for you coming back to
process and technique you mentioned a
whole bunch of questions what if David
Fincher yeah made this what if I'm
making this up but what if what what's
the commercial my mom would respond to
or whatever these questions might be I
think about questions a lot not just in
podcasting but in certainly writing the
non-fiction books that came before the
podcast interrogating myself when I'm
Journal I think about questions a lot
and the power of questions seems to be a
fundamental piece of creating creativity
right looking at something that a
million people have looked at and seeing
something different or seeing a way to
position it differently are there any
books on the ad game on
creativity that come to mind if somebody
were sitting in front of you like your
much younger self you're like okay this
kid's got some balls gender neutral and
is willing to step out of his or her
Comfort zon mhm okay I want to help this
kid what might you
recommend I have a prescription for that
let's go there's a book called Hey
Whipple squeeze this that's authored by
Luke Sullivan you know it this is one of
my books that I read so it is the the
most perfect one because it's I got to
go back and reread this now it it tells
you what an ad agency does does it have
a photograph of a roll of toilet paper
yes so Whipple was a grer in like some
1970s campaign and I think he was
selling toilet paper to customers and so
the logo is written on a on a double
roll of of paper it's a weird title but
one you don't forget and Luke just lays
out what an agency does what every job
is at the agency and then specifically
as a creative like what are the types of
things you're being asked to do and what
do those outputs look like it's an
amazing book it explains to you what a
headline writing assignment is and what
head lines look like and why some might
be better than other so it's a really
smart Trek you know micro apprenticeship
so I read it and I said I I'll be damned
if I don't do this cuz I I read it and I
was like I'm in that's it that told me
what the job was and I said that's
that's the only job I want to do so
anyone who you know now I think these
days people do ask to hop on and do
informational interviews but people will
sometimes even these days ask you to
like describe your job to them which I
always thought was a little crazy
because I you do want people to do some
level of leg work where they might know
what your job is and ask you a question
about it but but I just feel it
constantly with just please go read this
book and if you can't live without doing
what what's in this book then we'll get
time you know but that book is perfect
but then for like the creative Journey
or like even to understand what it's
like there's three three video bits of
content we were we were chatting about
them earlier uh number one South Park 6
days to air MH looking at the pressure
these guys are under to come up with and
do a show I don't know if it ages well I
think cuz you know the humor can be so
please don't judge me if the subject
matters is not PC you can judge me it's
pretty funny judge so that one goes to
Tim because he likes that show too but
it was I I will say that it's an it's an
amazing doc Min do there are a couple of
points where it drags a little bit but
there are so many payoffs there's so
many payoffs no but but even just the
thing of like when which one is the
blonde ones that Trey I can't remember
he's like the the writer writer out of
the two of them and once they've got the
story down and he has to like write the
script he has his assistant go get him
Extra Value Meal from McDonald's because
it's just so hard after all that to sit
down and then hammer it out and you know
as a writer and I know as a writer
sometimes you're like I I know I have to
do it but I don't want to so even
watching him like bribe himself watching
like one of the most dynamic prolific
edgy writers like he has to fool himself
into it and and by the way sometimes
when we make commercials we have to make
little animatics like little borom
matics like rips that's considered a
chore that whole show is a bomatic when
you watch how they make it so it's so
inspiring to see those to power through
and there's just a ton of stuff that
that you can relate to the two other
ones I love are um I love the Metallica
dock some kind of monster because it
gets into doing creative within a
team and chemistry and and how
challenging that can be and that
documents Metallica almost breaking up
and and working out their as they
come up with the Black Album M and it's
amazing and you don't have to like
Metallica to love it to see are you more
of a LS are you more of a James who do
you side with here you know so that's an
amazing study on high performing
creative Team Dynamics and then the last
one and the most underrated is Conan
O'Brien can't stop ah okay so he made
after that really painful departure from
The Tonight Show he had a non-compete so
he went he he threw a comedy tour and so
he allowed it to documented and you see
that this guy is a creative animal that
coming out of what he just came out of
or you must be so damaged and wounded
but he's throws himself right into
another Enterprise and they're writing
bits and skits and they're staying up
late at night the night before show to
rewrite it and just seeing the obsession
in the craft of it you're like I watch
the thing and I'm like I do not work
hard enough and you see the Euphoria and
like slap happiness around all of it
when you really push yourself that man
really pushes himself to his limits and
you watch that and you're like I just
want to go and write something after I
see that those things any one of those
things they inspire me so much that I've
just got a bank that someone else will
get something out of them can't wait to
watch some kind of monster and can't
stop I've seen the South Park Doc and
can you guess my favorite part where did
I laugh hardest well Tim I don't want to
be body but would it be the Apple user
agreement Human
Centipede it was the voiceover session
that was related to
that yes H there's a lot of good stuff
there's a lot of good stuff it's crazy
stuff wow hey Whipple squeez this I
haven't thought about that in ages I
used to have that book when I was really
cutting my teeth on copy and spending a
lot of my own money yeah doing very
expensive testing because the the lead
time and the turnaround time for any
type of quantitative feedback on
magazine ads I mean oh my God how
painful yeah I had that book
deliberately cover out on my shelf as a
reminder of some of the contents it's
been a very very long time but it's wild
that that that is that is now resurfaced
in my life what fun when it comes to the
the prompts and the questions are there
any other questions that come to mind if
you're stuck mhm and you're just like
man we've been banging our head against
the wall we're not there Y and I'm going
to lead this is going to lead into some
of the less glamorous maybe aspects of
the job right where it's like okay you
got to come up with X number of ideas
this is important and you're getting
close to deadline you don't have it yep
what do you do
to mix things
up and I suppose just broadly speaking
what do you do in a situation like that
well writer block doesn't really exist
you know you've got it it's you think
it's blocked but you clearly you can it
really is like a game of of tricking
yourself so like say Sally is trying to
come up with ideas what Sally what are
your five favorite movies or directors
or writers okay what would each one of
them do you it's just coming up with a A
new challenge or a new way to approach
it that fools you into coughing
something up and then again I'll go as
far as what's the the absolute right
thing to do what's the absolute wrong
thing to do what would I do if I if I
thought this whole thing was a big joke
if I wanted to make fun of it and and
again and then even the the cause
technique of just start writing
sentences and finish them but I think
it's no knowing yourself and knowing
your interests and then using Avenues so
what things you're into put it through
that lens but it's just it's a forcing
exercise and it's really uncomfortable
it's really really uncomfortable because
the more you get out you will find one
thing I have found and I don't think
it's just me I've talked to friends
about it is that 4H hour 5 Hour whatever
your big dump is later you will have new
ideas and things but the the biggest
treasure Trove you'll ever have is when
the challenge is fresh when your brain
is first trying to put put it together
and the more you get out of that moment
the more you're paid back later what do
you do when you're say overwhelmed or
unfocused right because this is a game
of creativity and we're all playing
different games right so all of our
careers on some level are are games of
different types of different types of
rules some you can bend some you can
break but
endurance is the ability to not just
flame out burning the candle at both
ends some people are superum and can you
know Bank all sorts of crazy work weeks
and sleep four hours a night because
they happen to have the right genetic
profile for that but what what do you do
when you're overwhelmed or unfocused
well interesting that you bring that up
because I I work with some of those
people that are I don't know if they
sleep and I am I'm sensitive and I need
sleep and so I'm I'm very very aware
that I'm not like a full
Beast so the question as you phrase it
there's kind of two answers that are
different but I read a book I know you
know this book called Bird by bird bird
oh so good so an amazing book and it's
going to some people will ignore it
because it's intended at face value for
fiction writers it does not matter it
does not matter I had to read it at
school so I'm talking about I must have
had a good teacher or whatever so I had
to read it what a gift I don't remember
a single thing in the book except for
the titular story mhm and that story was
and I you know I think about it all the
time and it's so the author's little
brother had to write report on the birds
and he had Books open and printed out
essays everywhere and he was in a full
meltdown and panic and he pushed it off
until the last the last minute get had
all semester to do it something like
that that whole thing everyone has a
version of that and he's there and I
think in my version of the story he's
like crying to the table with all that
stuff and then good old dad comes in and
goes just take it Bird by bird Bud take
it Bird by bird and you're like wow mhm
you know so I like I have an imaginary
father that comes in and says that to me
every time because it's permission
permission to stop thinking about the
totality of it and permission to do the
littlest bit the other quotation that I
love I don't have a ton of quotations
but the the great Arthur Ash said start
where you are use what you have do what
you can and that's so fantastically
empowering because it's saying that
you're in a good enough spot and you're
you're off the hook for anything more
than that you know yeah but then the
other part of it about being a beast in
the constant pressure is I've figured
out that I can't meditate I think I'm
too it's something I'll get to later in
life but I think I'm too I can't sit
still I can't be alone in my thoughts
and so I discovered that instead of
turning the dial down to zero I found
also that hard Fitness is another
meditative instead of going down to zero
it just puts me at a 10 and so every
morning I go do a similar workout that
gives me almost like an existential
crisis so that by the time I show up at
work this whatever this kind of fog of
anxiety that I used to live in it just
burns it off and I just am so calm for
the rest of the day because I've already
been through something tough in the
morning what is the workout there's a
gym in New York City called tone house
and there's just one of them I used to
exercise in college and I was in pretty
good shape and then I got to doing a lot
of writing and drinking beer and doing
writing and I kind of let it slip and I
think around
2015 back when people would upload
Facebook albums the night after you did
anything I went to a New Year's party
and there was like a picture of me on
New Year's Day and I was leaned over
like a table of food and I swear in my
head I look like Alfred Hitchcock or
something like it was like the way my
jacket lapel was open it came out on
this huge thing and I got so upset that
I looked up hardest workout in New York
and then like Bing there was like this
one oneoff gym called ton house and I
went that day on New Year's Day they
were open and the class is like a it's
the the founder is a guy Nam Alonzo
Wilson and he played D1 football and
played a little pro football and he when
he stopped playing he missed the
practices the way I describe it to
friends is it's like a 1our Under Armour
commercial that you're in where you're
just dropping the deck and jumping over
stuff and banging ropes and the heart
rate stays up the whole time and and so
the first time I did it I stepped out of
class after 10 minutes because the warm
warm-up is really intense cardio and I
vomited in the locker room and I stayed
up at night staring at the ceiling being
like I can't let this thing get me and
so I came back the week later and the
week later and kind of pulled me in and
now you know me and a fairly regular
group are there 5 days a week six days a
week and then we do other stuff but that
has been such a gift for me because I'm
just you know I used to walk around in
between meetings and I'm like should I
run am I like am I using my time well
like what I I would just ruminate on all
the things I could be doing wasn't doing
and something about really beating
myself up in the morning I just don't I
don't expend the energy worrying about
all those things I just focus on what
I'm focusing on so has made me normal
yeah you do you Rel inspiring me to to
double down I've
recently knock on wood largely address
this kind of crippling lower back issue
that has sidelined me for the better
part of the last year and I'm really
excited to get back into serious
exercise and this might sound strange
cuz I'm not built like a border collie
but you can't have a working dog and
like put that dog in an apartment all
day long the dog's going to go crazy and
I remember when I was training my dog
Molly and taking it super seriously
going like full Deep dive on dog
training and one of the lines that stuck
with me is a tired dog is a happy dog I
think that is true not for every person
but for people who have a certain
hardwiring and sounds like you're one of
them I am certainly one of them if
you're not putting that creature to work
physically all sorts of strange things
are going to creep out of the C tracks
not the best things because you want to
get a lot done and you need to be tired
out a little bit to be a little bit
normal about it yeah because if you're
going full energy you're doing what's in
front of you and you're freaking out
about all the other things you could
should might and when you're just a
little taken back a little bit you're
I'm more present it's great yeah I think
a lot of kids end up getting into
trouble in school because they're they
have idle cycles and they don't know how
to apply those Idol Cycles mean I
remember in school for me it's like I
needed to draw non-stop in grade school
I got very good grades I did really well
but I would get so bored in class I had
to draw all the time even though I was
listening to exactly what the teacher
was saying because I had to occupy
myself and I was fortunate that I
somehow chaned upon drawing but a lot of
other kids were very smart got into all
sorts of trouble got kicked out got
suspended ended up getting involved
drugs because they didn't know how to
occupy or consume those Cycles right and
exercise is an amazing way to do it any
other favorite books that you have or
put a different way books that you have
gifted or recommended a lot to other
people outside of what we've discussed
already I love this question because
it's I find like those are the things I
always jot down when I hear what people
gift two of them one of them is called
the easy way to quit smoking by Alan
Carr have you heard of this this is so
weird all of these things are are are
coming up in this conversation I listen
to
a a derivative of that but it's based on
the same method the easy way to quit
caffeine I listened to the Audi book
somebody had recommended to me and I
stopped I went 30 or 40 days without any
caffeine which is the first time I've
done that since I was like God Only
Knows 16 so please keep going but this
is in my 20s I smoked cigarettes and I
was hopelessly addicted to them and I
don't know how I found the book but I
read it and it told me bit by bit all
the reasons why I thought I had to keep
or why I would hang on to it and it
dispelled them one by one and it was
kind of romantic and then there's like a
chapter and it says go outside and have
your last cigarette and I went outside
and I did and then I finished the book
and I never smoked again and I talk
about it sparingly because the easy way
is kind of usually a red flag of
anything but that's what I love about it
if you look it up on Amazon the reviews
are in it is like five star for
thousands but I've given it to like four
or five friends and all four or five of
them just read it and never smoked again
wild so that book is probably a
life-saving book and then the other one
that I I love and I know you know this
book but the culture code by Daniel
Coyle you know I know the book and I
have not read it and it's been on my to
read list forever I think you would not
only love the book but you would love
talking to Daniel about that book
because you know I don't like business
books and especially when things become
dense and theoretical I get lost but he
went and and spent time in like 10
incredible High performing cultures that
are all different from like idio to the
San Antonio Spurs to the Navy Seals and
just identified what makes people feel
like they belong in those and what what
gives people the psychological safety to
do their best in those environments and
you read it and you'll you'll get
confirmation bias like I do that that's
great or or you're reminded I need to do
that or there's things you never thought
of now do you recommend this book to
people who are individual contributors
like kind of operators on the front
lines or do you give that to people who
are running companies like who do you
give that to I think for leadership for
sure so if anyone's stepping into
management but I also find you know it's
good I would imagine I would have loved
the book if I wasn't a manager just to
understand the kind of culture that I
want to be part of you know obviously
you know we're all students all the time
so I think there wouldn't be any harm in
imagining if you were to lead something
or if you were to have total control
what kind of culture you'd want but
definitely if you're in leadership or
you're stepping into leadership or if
you're stepping into a new role you know
there's just the simplest things you
could do to show that everyone you meet
that there's a long there's a long-term
potential future there and that's like a
you would forget to do but if you
reference something in the future some
minor things like that that you're like
oh that can make all the difference and
I understand having been on the
receiving end of those kind of behaviors
it's just great stuff but that one like
that's one of the few things that I
reread every year for the last two three
years okay I need to read it and I will
side note just because I I I made a a
mental bookmark to mention this to
people listening Conan O'Brien is so
impressive to me the more I learn about
that guy the more I see the more
impressed I am so Conan if you're
listening or friend of yours is
listening would love to chat sometime
publicly or privately there is a video
that I found actually was sent to me
because I went to Soul For the First
Time recently became deeply enamored of
Korea and the Korean people started
learning Korean studying the Korean
language and there's a video called
something like Conan O'Brien learns
Korean and makes it weird which is like
8 minutes long trust me folks find it on
YouTube it is beyond hilarious I've seen
it so good it ends with in the class
he's in the classroom right and he kind
of he's with the teacher and he's oh
yeah and he's amazing he's so fast so
fast on his feet
unbelievable and another just quick side
note because this is what I do Arthur
Ash another Legend iconic figure on so
many different levels and to take that
word a step further levels there's a
book called levels of the game by John
MC which is about One tennis match a
single tennis match involving Arthur Ash
but it becomes this study of the macro
through the micro and the structure of
the book The Narrative it is not a long
book it's something like 170 pages and
if you want to see why John MC is as
famous as he is for being a master of
non-fiction a staff writer for the New
Yorker for a thousand years this is an
amazing way to get a taste test it is so
so good you mentioned before we started
recording that you had an answer for the
under
$100 kind of best investment could be I
mean best investment is one way to put
it but device gadgets service anything
that you've spent kind of less than $100
on that has had a material impact on you
what is your answer for that my first
toon house class $34 that was the one
that was the $34 purchase that changed
everything is there anything else that
comes to mind maybe it's a second place
but just best investment that could be
investment time investment of energy
investment of money well I think
sometimes you ask about what what's
something you bought for under $100 mhm
that had a big return and you know how
work is you get caught up in things and
and there's you have your plan for the
week but then you wind up responding to
real time and conditions and you just
never know where it's going to go but I
go to Bazar restaurant in Manhattan on
Spring Street yeah and I take one of my
mentees I go with one of my mentors I go
with a a peer who I get a lot of energy
from or an old friend that I haven't
caught up with and the bill no matter
how you do it is always under a hundred
bucks with tip and it's always the best
$100 I spend every week it's the best
thing and I'll I'll never change it and
I'll even if I'm down to my last $100 I
will go have breakfast with someone it's
a great location I haven't been in a
million years so the reason I went by
the way too was like like everyone the
pandemic really was Challen alling and I
used to like Bazar but I didn't love
Bazar and when New York reopened a lot
of restaurants kind of popped out their
their Alfresco their outdoor cafes and
things like that and I would always walk
by a Bard and it was boarded up boarded
up boarded up and the owner Keith waited
until you could do full occupancy in
door before opening it and when he
opened it he did a post and I didn't
realize how much I missed it but his
post said Bazar is open and it will
never close again and I just you know
like coming out of that pandemic when
everyone's like everything's going to be
different they'll never just that
statement talk about communication that
kind of a subject line on an email I'm
like I will go there every week then as
long as you're open I'll go this is
going to sound like such a newbie
question but I'm curious do you in any
way keep track
of the ads or the messaging or the copy
that snag you right because that's
that's a hell of a line yeah like it's a
good line yeah right it worked it
absolutely worked do you have any these
could be ideas that you come up with too
but do you do you have any way of
capturing ideas whether they're yours or
things you come across in the wild where
you're like o wow that's good no I'm an
idiot and I forget no and I probably
probably 10 times a week I see things
where I'm like that's good and then I
remember one of them and if I was a
smart man I would have a notebook with
me at all times or I would put it in my
stickies and after this conversation I'm
going to collect them cuz now I'm
conscious cuz I see things all the time
and I'm like and that's you know they
come up at random times but I can't call
on them so I I would like to collect
better what I used to do because I
supposed to to invoke Glen Gary Glenn
Ross you must get them to sign on the
line that is dotted you can ask people
if they're going to buy something but ah
people are nice a lot of the time too
nice and they will tell you what they
think you want to hear getting someone
to actually buy something is a different
level of commitment right it's a
different type of signal so when I would
find myself compelled to buy something
especially when I didn't have very much
money and I was just getting started
cutting my teeth trying to build this
direct response business in Sports
Nutrition if I bought something or if I
got close to buying it I would save the
ad or I would take a video of the
infomercial or the commercial or I would
take notes on what what it was that I
thought got me to buy what you right
like was was it the like but wait
there's more there's an installment was
it the timing right like what do I think
it was yeah just pure fatigue on my part
where my defenses were low at 3 a.m.
because I've been watching Animal Planet
and it's God knows some Ginsu knife
thing came up and I I would try to
figure out although this was this was a
secondary thing what had moved me to buy
especially as someone who is not stingy
but had a really tight budget for most
things I no longer do that but what did
you learn
I learned a lot
about copy at the time I was reading a
lot of magazines and also
newsletters and mostly text because text
was easier to freeze and study y just
like for yourself journaling is thoughts
trapped on paper if you're trying to
figure something out by sitting there
and staring off into the space in
thinking sometimes it works often it
doesn't because it's too ephemeral right
these bits and pieces the floats some
Jets some it's just like being thrown
out of the boat in the Grand Canyon and
getting kind of tossed like you don't
really it's hard to orient to up when
you're in that type of chaotic mental
state with even if it's just too much
going on right if you have high energy
states so but for me journaling for
introspection but for
like external
studying it's not that text was the best
medium it was just the easiest for me to
to study as like a fly locked in the
Amber so what I learned was what kind of
headlines got me to look at anything
yeah right so if I'm reading a
magazine and especially I would read
magazines I wasn't even interested in
just to see what got my attention not
not to like really beat the drama on
Glen Gary Glen Ross which was actually a
very depressing movie on a lot of levels
when you get to the the bottom of it but
you know attention do I have your
attention like interested are you
interested the Aida the first thing is
attention so I would pick up say a
fashion magazine I'm like all right this
is going to be half at mhm and I would
just riff through and I would see what
would get me to stop and I'd be like
okay why did I just stop and I would
tear it out of the magazine might even
be at like a dentist's office or
something if I had downtime I would just
try to see what would grab my attention
and that was that was step one so you
learn a lot of things I mean this is I
don't want to go into a full monologue
here but I actually haven't talked about
this publicly I don't think first thing
you realize is how important art
direction is composition MH right do you
have a dominant element or is everything
the same if everything's the same your
eye isn't going to necessarily be drawn
to any one component and you're going to
skip over it generally there are some
weird exceptions where like the jumble
is The Branding for instance I have used
un scented baby soap from Dr Bronner for
ever because it's just like the least
offensive to my system and it's MH I
really like it they're branding if you
look at the bottle it's like size two
font with like a million words covering
the label I know that super old timey is
that the it's not there may be some old
timey aspect but it's it's very small
font it's kind of like unibomber
like Ransom lettery stuff like if you
actually dig into it it's not very easy
to follow all of it but it's full of
text but it's kind of like a a horseshoe
where it's or a horseshoe is not the
best way to explain it but it's like you
get to such a point of clutter that it
it becomes a clear signal again almost
as like a Gestalt form of branding so
there are some exceptions to that but
you realize like oh okay if you look at
the Volkswagen ads yeah if you look at
some of the old classics very reductive
reductive like okay and now I'm not
going to get the ratio totally right but
it's like all right the top 2third or
three4 of this ad is a bold visual often
black and white there's one tagline
that's like three to seven words and
then you've got some copy of the bottom
and like a a clip out coupon or
something for a lot of these direct
response ads so I studied the visual
element because I was actually buying
and in fact at the time I was designing
a lot of my own print ads so I was going
into like Photoshop and illustrator and
and doing a lot of the art I was doing
everything myself I couldn't afford to
hire you were advertising creative
before I was
uh I I learned a lot about Clarity and
also converting speeds and feeds into
benefits but you said that the two
things and I mean these are the the
power of our direction right to to pull
you into a world to to show you
something that's interesting or
attractive is incredible and it still
feels like art people you know great art
directors do not do it scientifically
they have principles but they're
expressing and exploring and then the
other thing is is with the
also the magical set of words that can
sell you someone I used to work with one
of my mentors Rob Schwarz who was used
to be the chief creative officer at tbwa
in Los Angeles back in the day he has a
saying that I repeat to everyone which
is clients by words you know we can come
to clients and assure them that we can
deliver across every social Channel and
every asset and do all the strategy
research but ultimately we're going to
give them a set of words that tells them
who they are who they can be and who
they are to their consumer and those
those magical words are kind of
everything and no matter what changes in
the industry clients buy words and
consumers like me buy words too totally
and I feel like even if you aren't
planning on playing offense in the sense
that you're not a writer you're not
crafting ads I feel like
everyone certainly everyone who's
listening to this should make a
deliberate study of words for defensive
purpose purposes because if you're on
social
media or in any media and of course you
are exposed to advertising all the time
you're exposed to Communications all the
time you can be manipulated very easily
if you're not aware of how your mind is
being controlled or it is being
controlled informed right if I'm not if
I say and this is cliche but like don't
think of a pink elephant Pink Elephant
Pink Elephant right it's yeah your mind
is very reactive in a lot of respects so
I feel like the study of words is the
study of yeah thoughts and the
malleability of thoughts which then
leads to the malleability of behavior I
mean if you really want to see how crazy
that can get you can watch these Netflix
specials like the push from this
Illusionist who's also an amazing
graphic artist or I should say visual
artist painter Darren Brown and these
are long features that are mostly about
social social engineering but just what
you can get someone to do if you profile
them properly have a delay hire
Confederates and in this particular case
the push is can you get someone off the
street and get them to the point where
they push someone off a building they
commit
murder just by scripting everything out
from start to finish it is horrifying I
have very mixed feelings about it from
an ethical perspective nobody gets hurt
he many more miracle I think is another
one which is is very well done the point
of all this is part of my fascination
with the Whipple book part of my
fascination with ads is for playing
offense right so building a business and
so on a lot of it is just wanting to
understand how humans work and the
practitioners are always going to be
ahead of the scientist and the
theoreticians right that's true and
exercise where it's like the coaches
they're going to get a lot wrong they're
going to get a lot right and they are
going to be able to see the stateof thee
art before the academics ever get their
hands on it so if you want to understand
how humans work one approach and these
are not mutually exclusive one approach
is to study psychology and so on another
is to just look how people are affected
and persuaded yeah so there are many
books that I've read like and I'm
blanking on his first name but Lun is
the last name words that work who is a I
believe a republican political
strategist and if I'm not mistaken I
read this a long time ago was
recommended to me by a very famous
entrepreneur and neither of us would say
we have much in common politically with
this guy at all but he came up with as
one example the death tax instead of
inheritance tax like the death tax and
and unappealing and just these a handful
of rebrands that became almost
impossible to sort of overturn in the
Zeitgeist you should study that right
that is that is there is a gold mine
there if you study that kind of thing so
yeah you asked what i' what I'd learned
I mean I continue to learn I continue to
study these things yeah and maybe I'm a
weirdo but I just it's it's so
fundamental to the existence the
day-to-day week to week month-to-month
of existence of anyone listening to this
and by the way you're going to have to
get a lot better at defense because
because everything's GNA get
everything's about to get so much more
overwhelming so much more personalized
like the number of pitches that I get
the number of pitches my friends get now
just in the last few months where intro
paragraphs are clearly crafted using
AI where it's that's going to take away
my email writing gift I better I better
I I I think it'll take a while it'll
take a while because I can see you can
still pretty easily discern uh but
you're going to have to get better at
defense if you want to preserve your
sanity and your ability to function
so let me let me ask a question that has
been sort of in the hopper for a little
while it's been gestating and it comes
back to Blue Sky Thinking and creative
brainstorming and then constraints right
because I'm listening to some of your
stories and I'm like man it'd be great
to sit down for my own business and be
like you know what I want to get Bill
Murray doing this in an ad I want to
have him in the cockpit of a space
shuttle yes I I already want to watch
this ad I like
it and then there are certain eventually
real world considerations like budget
like legal yeah and I'm wondering if
there are examples of like overriding
these constraints where it's worked out
or at what point you kind of bring
things back to earth right because if
you if you do it too early you it would
seem like it exactly yeah you know
there's no hard and fast rules I think
you know the nice thing about working at
Big agencies with big Brands is my
experience has always been if the idea
is good enough there's always more money
I think I can say that without getting
in trouble but it's it's true creative
people we need the we need the
constraints to push off against to to
have ideas that have tension and that
are going to be effective so I think we
try to know as much about that going in
as possible and sometimes you know
you'll you'll have a $10 million idea
for a$1 million budget and it's a
tragedy because it would be amazing and
and and they would probably get great
Roi on it and it might make economic
sense but I think you sorry am quoting
everyone in their mother but another one
of my mentors Rob Riley who's the chief
creative officer of the wpp holding
company always says no client ever fired
you for bringing bringing extra ideas
and so I think a great line you know
some of the best things we've ever
gotten away with have been a Lucky
Strike extra you know or saying okay
here's the here's the thing you asked
for but by the way I know this would
involve getting a few celebrities or
opening the coffers but what about this
and and I think once you've taken the
the defenses down by showing what's
within possibility you buy yourself
Goodwill and permission to bring a crazy
idea and you're going to be sharing that
crazy idea with someone who's not
nervous about what's to come they're
going to enjoy it and so by and large
you C you can get there with that but
yeah I think you got to cover your bases
first or else yeah they'll be pissed at
you EBS is funniest ad of the Year yep
could you give us some context on this
on this prompt this is it's like you're
in my head Tim because this you've just
connected it and maybe you already know
where it's going my creative partner
when I was at BBD was a guy named Dan
Lucy and he and I he's my best friend
and you know and for eight years I spent
more time with him than I spent with my
wife sharing an office and finishing
each other's sentences and fighting all
the time too we had a new client in Foot
Locker and their aspiration was to to
not be this this kind of transactional
house of Brands but to for for holding
the Foot Locker bag to mean something we
knew there was big ambition there it
wasn't just just about like the shoes
that were in stock it was about trying
to make the brand cultural so we we
worked together on Foot Locker for about
five or six years and we created an
ongoing campaign where we got
celebrities and athletes to make fun of
themselves and and you know kind of play
it close to the Bone so part of this is
we had a great client a guy named Jed
Burger who he didn't come up from
traditional marketing he' come from
Modells which is an East Coast Sports
store I know Modell you know Modell what
else he also founded a basketball
magazine called dime magazine and he he
had other interest besides just
marketing so he was kind of came at
things from a cultural place so
sometimes we would show him ideas that
that got to the bone of sports issues or
athlete issues and he always championed
it so this was our first kind of big
campaign and we o overs swung the fences
like like crazy like there was maybe you
know money for a for a cameo and an ad
and instead we came up with this
cockamamy idea that for this one week
Foot Locker was putting out the very
best shoes they were just going to stack
it one day after another and the client
had called it the week of greatness and
so we had written an ad that said you
know basically what's happening at Foot
Locker it almost feels like with all
these shoes coming out it feels like all
is right in the world and then we leave
that scene and we go and we see a bunch
of wrongs be writed and impossibilities
happen and so we wrote the script and it
had Mike Tyson answering the door and a
Vander Holyfield is there with a box and
Mike Tyson Returns the the piece of the
ear that he bit off of Vander so already
we're showing that to to the rest of the
team at bbdo and they're like that's
never going to happen and then we're
like don't worry it keeps going you know
Dennis Rodman this is but wait there's
more 2012 kind of joke Dennis Rodman
what did we all want to see he he was at
an airline counter and he buys a oneway
ticket to North Korea they're like
that's never going to happen and then
and they're like but wait there's more
because Brett farv would refuse to
retire so Brett farv is going to make a
joke about you know retiring you know
he's at a diner and he's got a piece of
pie and he hands it back to the lady
half eaten and says he it's time to
stop so one at the other everyone said
you can't bring this to them because
this is going to cost a bajillion
dollars they never going to do it this
is not they ask us for something simple
and you've given something incredibly
complicated and this is I would say kind
of halfway through my journey and you
know there's probably a period usually
around the halfway point where you're
like maybe a little more arrogant than
you than you are later in the beginning
and so Dan and I just went nah we're
going to do it and so we got in such a
blowup fight uh with our account lead
that he he saidwell you know what you're
going to tank this whole thing and I'm
not going to go to the meeting and so we
went sounds good so we went down to the
meeting by ourselves without our
business partner who forsook us as a
matter of Pride and principal we
presented it to to this guy Jed and he
went I love it let's do it so
you know you you've got to take your
chances you know there's no shame in it
and and we would have had the you know
and he knew and Jed knew we would have
had the back we can write him a cheap
bad but we have a great one and then and
so he you know he went to batford and he
went and he you know he negotiated our
client negotiated with with all those
athletes and people and a little Side
Story which for any sports nerds will be
really fun is we filmed the Brett Favre
segment in Hattisburg Virginia and so
Dan went down there with the camera crew
to pick that up he gave us half an hour
because he was a high school football
coach in his first season retired and he
famously had you know hung on to things
in Green Bay and kind of as The Story
Goes prevented a young Aaron Rogers from
ascending and taking the starting
quarterback spot year after year and so
there was there's tension there and that
was you know famously or in the press a
bad relationship and Dan calls me from
set and he says I was just standing next
to Brett Favre in between shots and I
saw him open his Fantasy Football on his
phone and Aaron Rogers is his starting
quarterback and I was like God that is
such fun Intel to get from the front
line and I I swear we were like should
we call like Bleacher Report and tell
them this it's so people sports fans
would have loved to know that I really
have have two questions there are 50
more I'm just going to give some teasers
that we won't get to why that why what
if it's something that someone really
wants to know about and then we didn't
do it well then maybe we do around two
okay fair enough fair
enough so the time Kanye tried to get
you fired yeah okay we're not going to
do that although I I really I really do
at some point want to talk about that
cuz just The Limited context that I have
see makes it seem really hilarious it
was pretty good okay okay okay actually
I'll let you choose you know what this
is going to be this this is going to be
not dealer's choice this will be your
choice Gamers choice so that's gambler's
choice this is one option another option
is you on the cusp of taking your name
off of the Guinness wheelchair
basketball ad yeah and what that was all
about and just how that unfolded the
Kanye is easy but but we'll we'll save
that for another time time the
wheelchair basketball one because there
was a good lesson in it which is so Dan
the partner I mentioned and another guy
named Tom Kramer and I pitch that ad and
again what is the ad so in the ad a
group of it's almost like you start in
like a Nike ad or or in a scene from the
movie murderball which is a movie that
features wheelchair basketball you're
just a really intense game a wheelchair
basketball and you get seduced into it
you you follow the team down one end of
the to the other and you you think it's
all about performance or drive or what
these guys are
doing and as the game resolves the
surprise is that nine out of the 10 guys
get up out of their chairs to leave the
gymnasium and then one friend is still
in the chair and you understand that
that this group of friends all
participated in wheelchair basketball so
that they could play with their friend
who's in a wheelchair the line we had
was made of more for Guinness and it was
it's simple it's one of those great
lines where the beer itself is
complicated but also it's maybe a drink
that maybe someone who who wants to feel
like they're of more substance or or
that there's something more substantial
in that moment would choose so the brief
we gave ourselves was what's a story you
would tell that you would wish you could
do that for a friend or if your friends
did that for you that would mean
everything so it was just it was kind of
writing that way so it's very simple and
that was what was pitched and that's
probably what anyone who saw the ad saw
but what happened was our experience
making it was was not great we were
pretty hard-headed at that time was
right right around the the Foot Locker
time where we were maybe a little more
rambunctious and a little fighty and we
had a client that also was a little
rambunctious and fighty and I think
early on for whatever reason I think
there was like a sense of distrust that
wasn't solved when we were going to
produce the ad and and for whatever
reason we didn't quell it we fought it
so we brought forward the director we
wanted and the client didn't like
something about the director's treatment
the director will write a synopsis of
how they plan to tell the story and
instead of saying okay we hear you let's
go back and rewrite it we tried to push
back we tried to win the fight and as I
think I mentioned from My Adidas
experience you know you can't really win
these fights you've got to play it
collaboratively and forward but we ended
up basically just just every single
thing was a fight and ultimately we lost
every fight and it got to the point
where you know the the director was
challenged and the casting was
challenged and the Wardrobe of one of
the actors that wasn't even the lead
actor was why would you choose green
shoes and we like green shoes but it
didn't matter but we lost and then they
weren't green shoes and there was a red
stripe in the gym and why is there a red
stripe that's Budweiser's color and
we're like it doesn't matter and then
instead of just saying we'll change it
we'll paint it out so we fought
everything we lost everything and we
just felt like such losers by the time
we were done the music wasn't the TR we
like the set of words had to be
Rewritten cuz it wasn't right and we
were so down and we were so miserable
and sad that when it got released the
three of us said we're going to take our
names off it because this is this this
stank we just you know it's it's it's
garbage because maybe of our egos the 30
battles we lost along the way that must
have meant it was crap you know and so
maybe it was subconscious but we never
made that phone call even though we
intended to I think we got busy so we
didn't ask for our names to be taken off
of it but we intended to and then it
aired with no Fan Fair on a playoff
baseball game in October that I wasn't
watching the ad was not on YouTube
Someone videoed it on their phone one
when it maybe on their DVR uploaded it
to YouTube and by the morning it had
over a million views I don't even know
how anyone found it I don't even know
how you could search it but it just kind
of went through the roof because it
touched the thing that we wanted to
touch where everyone felt God I would do
that for someone or I I I pray I have
people around me that would do that for
me but we missed the the whole point
because we were so caught up in the 30
things we lost we missed the story was
still intact and it was still good but
we were obsessed about our own personal
experience on it that made us lose faith
in it and so it's just that constant
reminder to like step back ask yourself
if you're feeling a certain way does it
really matter is it really changing
things or are you just caught in the
weeds so that was a big lesson for me to
get outside of my own attitude about
stuff were you able to change
your
behavior in future projects because of
that I think so yeah I think so I think
I I think it was a clear lesson that a
lot of things we thought mattered don't
matter so maybe we need to be a little
more a little more meanful to feedback
and suggestion you know yeah totally um
but it was good good life there was a
work lesson and A Life Lesson so lessons
not that you have to impart a lesson but
the billboard question so if you could
put a message a quote an image anything
on a billboard non-commercial
metaphorically speaking just to get
something in front of a lot of people
yeah what would you put first thing is I
would request the billboard location
would be at my house because I want to
see it every day because I'm whatever
matters to me is probably the thing that
I need to be reminded of more than I
need to
broadcast but I would just say in the
spirit of creativity and living an
interesting life see what's possible see
what's possible see what's possible what
would that mean to you if it were in
front of your house what would that how
would that be helpful to you it would
remind me every day that I'm not living
a routine but but I'm here to see what I
can do and and what people around me can
do and how how can I how can we I don't
like the word maximize because that
sounds maybe a little functional but
like how can you fully Express in life
by Taking Chances by believing in
yourself by trying new things and it can
mean anything to anyone but it's just
that reminder of I'm not here to do what
the plan is today I'm here to see what's
possible I love it Chris we are winding
to a close is there anything else that
you would like to well first of all any
websites places to point people to that
you'd like to mention and then is there
anything you'd like to say before we
come to a
close well first of all thank
you the best place to find me is
LinkedIn because I tend to post a lot
about creativity and work and work that
we're doing a work that that I find
inspiring so it's it's a good place to
engage and I hope anyone out there you
know we were talking before we started
that when I was 21 a career in
advertising was one of the few options
for a creative person today you can
self-publish you can become an
influencer you can write your own movie
you can publish your own novel it's not
as attractive but I hope I hope we
continue to attract the best talent and
I hope people do pursue it because it's
a really fun job you learn about all
kinds of different businesses they tell
you all their secrets about about why
things aren't working how good their
product really is and you get to come up
with ideas to solve it and if you hit it
you know you get to put them out into
the world and get your ideas in front of
hopefully millions of people and I think
it's probably a career that doesn't seem
as as illustrious as it used to be but
my hope is that is that we continue to
bring great people in because that's the
only way it's going to be vibrant and
exciting and by the way otherwise you're
just going to have horrible ads on TV or
where whatever screen we look at so it's
kind of like let's get good people in
this industry so that we don't have to
look at horrible Marketing in the future
yeah and you also get to collaborate
right it's a big it's a big one I mean a
lot of people out there I think have
lost sight of the possibility of
collaborating in these types of
environments and these types of
companies
because the shiny object for a lot of
young people is running your own ship as
an influencer but there are a lot of
trade-offs and one of them that I know
from having spoken to a lot of people
who are creators independently is you
can end up being or feeling very
isolated and very lonely right and one
of my top priorities in fact I just
finished an offsite recently for my
whole team was of fast creative
collaborations with worldclass people
because you can do a lot as a solo
operator even with a team but if you're
in isolation you're not going to be
broadening at least I don't think for me
personally your
horizons you're not going to be like
bending and testing your perception of
the world in a way that you could yeah
in a collaborative environment yeah so
we will link to your LinkedIn in the
show notes for everyone and we will link
to everything we've discussed in the
show notes everybody at tim. blogpeople